Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von der ESA und dem DLR. Ja, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das ist jetzt hier mittlerweile schon die 14. Ausgabe, in der es immer um interessante Dinge gehen soll und so auch dieses Mal ein ganz spezieller Blick auf die Raumfahrt. Dazu habe ich mich wieder mal nach Oberpfaffenhofen begeben, auf das große DLR-Gelände an ein Institut, wo ich bisher noch nicht war. Und zwar dem Institut für Robotik und das bestimmt heute auch das Thema. Es soll um die Robotik gehen und zwar im Allgemeinen, aber auch vor allem im Besonderen, welche Rolle die Robotik in der Raumfahrt spielt und spielen kann. Und dazu begrüße ich den Gesprächspartner für heute, nämlich Klaus Landzettel. Ja, du bist jetzt hier schon eine Weile beschäftigt bei diesem Institut. Seit wann?
Seit 1970, also inzwischen 40 Jahre hier im DLR.
Oha, naja, das dürfte ja für ein guter Überblücksmöglichkeit sorgen.
Ja, ich denke.
Da hat sich aber doch so einiges getan in dem Feld in den letzten 40 Jahren, würde ich mir vorstellen.
Ja, sicher. Als ich hier angefangen habe, hier in Oberpfaffenhofen, hat das Gelände schon mal ganz anders ausgeschaut, als es heute aussieht. Es gab viele Gebäude damals noch nicht, die wir heute hier kennen. Und auch die ganze Arbeitsweise hat sich natürlich in den letzten 40 Jahren drastisch verändert. Wenn man allein darüber nachdenkt, Computertechnik, was gab es damals, wie schaut es heute aus, es sind Riesenunterschiede und Fortschritte gemacht worden, bei denen ich das Glück hatte, immer mit dabei zu sein. Das heißt, man ist quasi mit der Technologie mitgewachsen in den letzten 40 Jahren. Und das ist eine Riesenchance gewesen, auch vom Verständnis her mitzukommen. Ich sage mal, damit hat man es fast leichter, als wenn man heute mit dem Riesenfortschritt, den die Technologie inzwischen gemacht hat, plötzlich konfrontiert wird. Wenn man mit reinwachsen kann, versteht man manche Dinge einfach von den Grundlagen besser. Und die Chance hatten wir damals.
Ja, ich denke auch, es ist wichtig, immer so den historischen Kontext auch zu sehen. Da erklären sich die Dinge manchmal dann auch von ganz alleine, wenn man sich gerade fragt, warum heißt denn das jetzt so?
Also wenn man sich vorstellt, dass damals Computer noch Drehstromanschlüsse hatten, Speicher von 4 Kilobyte eine riesen Datenmenge waren. Und man hat sich so langsam hochgehangelt, Stückweise. Man musste Programme optimieren, ja keine Kommentare ausgeben. Man musste ja mit jedem Byte sparen, was in dem Programm gespeichert werden musste und so weiter.
Und bei welchen Ausbildungsweg bist du denn überhaupt an das Thema herangekommen? Robotik dürfte es ja dann so als Studium noch nicht gegeben haben.
Nee, ich hab an der FH Darmstadt Nachrichtentechnik studiert und hab dann anschließend noch bei der Fernuniversität Mathematik und Physik belegt, um mir das Know-how in Mathe etwas aufzubügeln. Und hab mich dann eigentlich mehr oder weniger auch selber weitergebildet hier im DLR. Ich bin seit wie gesagt 1970 hier. Habe damals angefangen mit Hardware-Entwurf für Computer. Daher auch das Verständnis, wie funktioniert ein Computer überhaupt.
Also wurden hier noch richtig Computer entwickelt?
Ja, ich hab damals angefangen und hab analog ein Ausgabegeräte entwickelt, damit man zum Beispiel irgendwelche Geräte über ein Computer steuern konnte. Das war damals ganz neu. Man muss sich vorstellen, dass 1970 Computer mit Lochstreifen programmiert wurden. Also der Compiler, der Linker, das war alles ein Lochstreifen, der dann den Source Code rein geholt hat, Object erzeugt. Und das war einfach eine ganz andere Arbeitsweise, als man sich heute vorstellt. Und ich kann mich gut dran erinnern, das erste Mal, als man nicht mehr mit Lochstreifen gearbeitet hat, sondern mit einem normalen Editor am Bildschirm gesessen ist, dann habe ich irgendwie mein Programm gesucht, weil ich konnte es nicht mehr anfassen.
Wo ist denn mein Programm, das lag da immer auf dem Tisch?
Die Editoren waren dann auch so, dass man zeilenweise nur ändern konnte. Also wenn ein Buchstabe falsch war, muss man die ganze Zeile neu eingeben. Aber das war schon ein Riesenvorteil gegenüber Lochstreifen und Lochkarten. Also der Zwischenschritt war ja dann die Lochkarte. Und dann konnte man das Programm auch noch anfassen, man konnte also jede einzelne Programmzeile eine Karte haben. Und die wurde dann eingelesen, daraus wurde wieder ein Object erzeugt, gelingt und so weiter. Also das war, wenn man da ein Programm was ändern wollte, nicht so wie man das heute tut, man tippt kurz eine Änderung ein und das Programm macht das dann schon. Ich habe heute Entwicklungsumgebungen, wo auch Fehler direkt von Debugger in dem Source Code angezeigt werden und der springt sofort dahin, wo das Problem liegt. Das sind alles Dinge, die gab es damals nicht.
In Ägypten musste jeder Stein noch einzeln auf die Pyramide gemacht werden und heute gießt man Stahlbeton.
Genau, da waren Wechselplatten, das war dann so eine riesen Errungenschaft, dass man also Daten auf Wechselplatten speichern konnte. Die hatten einen Durchmesser von 60-70 Zentimetern und da haben zwei Megabyte draufgepasst, nur mal um die Größenordnung sich vorzustellen. Und so der erste große Schritt, kann ich mich erinnern, das war eine Digital Equipment PDP 1160, die hatte 128 Kilobyte Speicher. Und da haben wir eigentlich sehr große Programmsysteme damals schon drauf programmiert. Das war so Anfang der 80er Jahre. Allerdings mit dem Trick, dass man Programme in Scheibchen aufgeteilt hat. Und immer das, was gerade aktuell gebraucht wurde, wurde über ein spezielles Programm von der Festplatte hochgeladen in den Speicher und dann ausgeführt. Und so wurden einzelne Programm-Module im Speicher ausgetauscht zur Laufzeit. Das war eine ganz spezielle Programmiertechnik damals.
Das ist auf jeden Fall fast noch mal ein eigenes Thema wert. Aber wie kam es denn dann sozusagen zu dem Thema Robotik in deinem Werdegang?
Das war so, dass dadurch, dass ich mich lange Zeit hier mit Prozess-Rechentechnik beschäftigt hatte und auch sehr viele Interfaces für Computer entwickelt haben, wie man irgendwelche Geräte ansteuern kann, dann hatten wir eine Verbindung zu einem Institut in Lörrach. Die haben damals einen ersten Roboter gebaut, Zindlmann hieß der, und der wurde analog angesteuert. Und so bin ich damit reingerutscht in die Robotertechnik. Ich habe damals angefangen, Roboter mit einem Computer zu verbinden. Das gab es noch nicht. Und die wurden damals die Gelenkmotoren analog angesteuert. Das heißt, aus dem Rechner kommen Spannungen raus, die entsprechen einer Gelenkwinkelstellung, und die muss der Manipulator anfahren. Das war der erste Schritt Richtung Robotik hier.
Der Manipulator ist was genau?
Das sind sechs Gelenkmodule, sechs Motoren, die ähnlich wie beim menschlichen Arm, wo wir unsere Gelenke haben, eben Gelenke bewegen. Der Manipulator damals bestand aus sechs einzelnen Gelenken.
Also generell als Manipulator bezeichnet man quasi die Motortechnik oder was auch immer zum Einsatz kommt, was den Roboter in irgendeine Stellung bringt.
Richtig, also der Manipulator ist das gesamte System. Das sind die Gelenke, die Gelenkeinheiten, die die Bewegung ausführen und dazwischen die Verbindungsteile. Man kann Manipulator kurz oder lang bauen. Das sind die Zwischenelemente. Und das Ganze bezeichnet man als Manipulator-System. Dahinter steckt natürlich eine Steuerung, weil ich muss das Ding ja auch bewegen können. Die ersten Versuche, wie bewegt man einen Roboter, waren so, dass man versucht hat, in einem Computer gewisse Gelenkwinkel auszurechnen und die an den Manipulator, an die Gelenksteuerung zu übergeben, sodass die dann gewisse Gelenkstellungen im Raum einnehmen. Das war so der erste Schritt. Wie kann man denn ein Manipulatorsystem von einem Computer ausbewegen? Das gab es damals noch nicht.
Das heißt, der Roboter war vorher eigentlich im Prinzip, wie man das so aus alten Science-Fiction-Filmen kennt. Man steckt so auf der einen Seite den Arm in so eine Muffe und so wie man den dann bewegt, so bewegt man dann auch den Roboter. Also quasi analog zur Handbewegung.
So hatten die damals in Larach diesen Roboter konzipiert. Der wurde über ein sogenanntes Exoskelett. Also wie du sagst, der Mensch schlüpft mit seinem Arm in ein Gerät rein. Da werden die Gelenkwinkel vom Schultergelenk, Ellenbogen, Handgelenk gemessen. Und diese Informationen wurden dann analog an das Roboter-System übergeben, dass dann die gleichen Bewegungen ausführt. Und dazwischen haben wir jetzt dann den Computer geschaltet. Die Probleme dabei sind erst mal, dass man sich erst mal überlegen muss, welche Gelenkstellungen brauche ich denn, um einen bestimmten Punkt im Raum zu erreichen. Das waren so die ersten Schritte, die wir dann hier im Institut durchgezogen haben. Wir haben eine Software entwickelt, die die Koordinatentransformation durchhört. Das heißt, wenn ich einen bestimmten Punkt im kathetischen Raum erreichen will, dann gibt es, wenn ich nur sechs Gelenke habe, eine ganz bestimmte Gelenkstellung für jedes einzelne Gelenk, damit ich diesen Punkt im kathetischen Raum erreiche. Und diese Transformation haben wir damals auch hier im Institut entwickelt, sodass man dann kathetisch steuern kann. Das war ein Riesenfortschritt gegenüber der Robotensysteme, die man bis dahin erkannt hat.
Also vorher musste man sozusagen die Schritte irgendwie wissen oder ahnen. Und jetzt könnte man sagen, ich will, dass er genau dahin zeigt. Und daraus ergibt sich dann folgende Stellung.
Also der Unterschied war, wenn ich über so ein Exoskelett arbeite, mit dem ich mit dem Arm reinschlupfe, dann stelle ich ja die Gelenkwinkel mit meinem eigenen Arm an. Die werden simultan an das Roboter-System übergeben und er erreicht, wenn er alles richtig macht, genau die gleiche Gelenkstellung. Wenn ich das Ganze aber von Computer aus vorgeben möchte, dann muss ich das, was der Mensch macht, wenn wir einen bestimmten Punkt anfahren, dann denken wir auch nicht groß drüber nach, sondern wir tun das einfach. Es ergeben sich automatisch gewisse Stellungen der Schultergelenke, Geldboden.
Man weiß einfach, wie man seinen Arm bewegen muss.
Genau. Und das weiß der Computer oder der Roboter eigentlich von Haus aus nicht. Das heißt, man muss ihm eine Software verpassen, die in der Lage ist, genau das zu tun. Und das ist die inverse Kinematik. Das heißt, ich gebe einen kathetischen Punkt vor. Und dieses Programm rechnet mir die dazu passenden Gelenkstellungen aus.
Inverse Kinematik. Warum nennt man das so? Ach so, weil das so eine rückwärts...
Inverse Transformation.
Das heißt, man geht vom Ziel aus und rechnet den Weg zurück zu dem, wo man jetzt gerade ist.
Und das Umgekehrte ist die direkte Koordinatentransformation. Die geht von gegebenen Gelenkwinkelstellungen aus und rechnet dann einfach zurück auf den Punkt im Raum, den der Greifer oder der Endpunkt des Manipulados erreichen wird.
Das heißt, das ist ein bisschen der Urknall der digitalen Robotik, dass man überhaupt dieses Grundproblem erst mal gelöst hat.
Das musste erst mal gelöst werden. Dass man in der Lage ist, so ein Manipuladosystem gezielt zu steuern. Das heißt, dass ich vorgeben kann, fahr mir diesen Punkt präzise an. Das gab es nicht. Man hat sich vorher, wenn die ersten Versuche waren, dass man sich überlegt, dass man gelenkweise gesteuert hat. Das heißt, ich habe angefangen, mit einem Gelenk mich zu bewegen und habe mich dann so, wie man so schön sagt, hingehangelt an den Punkt, an den ich eigentlich hinfahren wollte. Aber die inverse Kinematik-Transformation macht das nicht.
Also dieser klassische Robot-Dance. Ja, aber so kann man nur so einen Arm gleichzeitig...
So kann man natürlich nicht arbeiten. Man möchte ja Roboter irgendwo einsetzen, auch in der Industrie, um den Menschen zu unterstützen. Und ich kann mich gut erinnern, wir haben damals das erste Mal eine Ölpumpen-Montage mit einem Manipulator durchgeführt. Also da muss der Manipulator dann schon ganz gezielt an die einzelnen Objekte, die er da zusammenbauen soll, herangeführt werden. Und das schafft man eigentlich wirklich nur, indem man entsprechend den Tool Center Point, also den Greifpunkt des Manipulators kathesisch vorgibt und die Software dafür sorgt, dass die Gelenke entsprechend richtig angesteuert werden.
Das geht aber jetzt immer noch davon aus, dass man quasi den Aktionsraum auch zu 100 Prozent unter Kontrolle hat und auch kennt und weiß genau, wo die Objekte sind, die man heranfahren will. Da ist jetzt noch keinerlei Sensorik mit ins Spiel gewesen.
Das war noch ohne Sensorik. Also wir hatten ein Sensorsystem entwickelt. Das ist eine kleine Kugel, die kann Kräfte und Momente messen. Die fasse ich an mit der Hand. Und jetzt kann man hergehen und sagt, die Kräfte, die transponiere ich auf translatorische Bewegung vom Arm. Und die Drehmomente, die ich auf die Kugel eingebe, das sind die Rotationen. So, und jetzt habe ich sechs Freiheitsgrade in der Kugel. Also habe ich drei Translationsrichtungen und drei Rotationsrichtungen. Und damit kann ich bequem, wenn ich diese Kugel, die Kugelkommandos so transformiere, dass sie den, ich sag mal, den Greifpunkt des Manipulators betreffen, dann kann ich den kathäzig durch die Gegend fahren. Und die Koordinatentransformation sorgt dafür, dass die entsprechenden Gelenkwinkel eingestellt werden. Und das war so das erste Mal, wo man ein Sensorsystem hatte, womit der Mensch mit dem Manipulator zusammenarbeiten kann.
Der Sensor wurde sozusagen nur als User Interface benutzt.
Der Sensor, wollte ich eben gerade sagen, ist als Eingabegerät damals gedacht. Das war schon mal ein Riesenfortschritt. Man hatte quasi in einer Hand die Möglichkeit, mit einer Hand einen Manipulator ganz zielgerichtet in seinem Arbeitsraum zu bewegen. Daraus wurde dann natürlich gleich die nächste Idee geboren. Man kann ja auch diese Sensor-Kugel, wie wir die genannt haben, vorne am Manipulator befestigen, an seiner Hand. Jetzt kann ich diese Kugel als Operator packen und führe ihn an dieser Kugel durch seinen Arbeitsraum. Das wäre die andere Methode der Bewegungsvorgabe. Der Manipulator spürt dadurch, dass ich ihn an der Kugel packe, dann kann ich diese, kann ich viel feinere Bewegung vorgeben. Ich bin direkt vor Ort, ich habe den Manipulator mit seinem Greifer quasi in meiner Hand und führe ihn ganz genau dahin, wo er hinfahren sollte. Und diese Bewegung, die konnte man aufzeichnen und damit dann immer wieder den gleichen Ablauf ablaufen. Das funktioniert dann so lange, wie sich seine Umgebung nicht verändert. In dem Moment, wo in der Umgebung irgendwas verändert ist, dann braucht er Sensorik.
Was war denn so die primäre Anwendungsidee jetzt dabei? Reden wir jetzt hier von Industrierobotern, diesen typischen, wir bauen mal ein Auto zusammen, Anwendungen? Oder hat sie das schon andere?
Ja, es gab Anwendungen, wie ich vorher schon erwähnte, mal zu demonstrieren. Man kann mit einem Roboter so eine komplexe Aufgabe, wie zum Beispiel Montage einer Ölpumpe, das kann man mit einem Manipulator durchführen. Oder Entgraden von Lenkrädern. Das war mal eine Aufgabe, die hatten wir auch bei unserem Institut erledigt. Und zwar Lenkräder, das ist diese Gummimasse, die wird um das Lenkrad rumgepresst. Und dann gibt es an der Nahtstelle so einen überstehenden Grad.
Der muss weg.
Und der muss weg. Und da haben wir ein System entwickelt. Und mit einem kleinen Skalpell, das hatte der Manipulator-Fahner an seiner Spitze dran, ist er genau diesen Grad entlanggefahren und hat diesen Grad dann abgeschnitten. Das war aber nicht mehr reingesteuert, also dass ein Operator ihn da rumführt und fest eine Bahn einlernt, sondern dazu benötigt der Manipulator ja selber eine Sensorik. Das heißt, er muss spüren, wie stark drücke ich hingegen das Lenkrad. Oder wenn ich an die Ölpumpenmontage denke, wie verklemme ich gerade einen Bolzen, den ich in ein Loch einfügen möchte. Das ist übrigens ein Riesenproblem damals noch gewesen. Wie fügt man denn kraftgeregelt einen Bolzen in ein Loch ein, ohne dass sich das Ding verklemmt? Das heißt, dazu haben wir dann dieses Prinzip der Sensorkugel, die ja Kräfte und Momente messen kann, so umkonstruiert, dass man das an der Handwurzel des Manipulators, also quasi hinter dem Greifer zwischen Greifer und Handgelenk, wurde ein Kraftmomentensensor integriert, der dann genau die Kräfte messen kann, die der Manipulator gegen seine Umgebung auswirft.
Das heißt, dasselbe Kugelprinzip, was man vorher so zur Steuerung gemacht hat, was erst mal die Kräfte aus dem Arm auf diese Kugel gelegt hat, die dann was gesteuert haben, da hat man im Prinzip umgedreht. Und jetzt ist es das Objekt, was man hat mit seinen Gegenkräften, wirkt auf diesen Manipulator zurück. Wie nennt man diese Kugel denn genau, diesen Sensor?
Das ist ein Kraftmomentensensor.
Kraftmomentensensor.
Der kann Kräfte und Momente messen. Drückt das aus, was das Ding eigentlich tut. Den hatten wir angesetzt, um Kräfte und Momente zu messen, die der Manipulator gegen seine Umgebung ausübt. Jetzt muss man aber dafür sorgen, dass diese gemessenen Sensorinformationen natürlich auf die Bewegung des Arms wieder einwirken. Das heißt, im Programm, im Steuerungsprogramm für den Manipulator kommen einmal die Eingabewerte vom Operator rein, der den Manipulator kathäsisch verfährt. Und wenn der Manipulator jetzt vorne an seiner Handspitze Kräfte spürt, dadurch, dass er zum Beispiel einen Bolzen schräg in ein Loch einsetzt, dann versucht er das zusätzlich auszugleichen. Und damit kann ich ihm einfach einen Vorschub geben. Ich sage, drück den Bolzen mal nach unten ins Loch und regel dabei die Kräfte aus, die du über deinen eigenen Sensor spürst.
Also im Prinzip genau das, was man auch so selber in der Hand spürt, wenn man irgendwas reintritt, man merkt einfach, es klemmt, es ist jetzt einfach mehr Widerstand, als man meint, dass es eigentlich da sein müsste, wenn man etwas reinschraubt. Also man hat sozusagen so eine messbare Nenngröße und wenn die überschritten wird, dann weiß man so, hm, vielleicht nochmal lockern und so.
Dieses Gefühl, der Manipulator hat das Gefühl, spürt genau das Gleiche, was wir auch spüren würden, wenn wir diesen Bolzen in das Loch einsetzen. Und diese ganze Steuerungstechnik hat man damals oder nennt man Shared Control. Das heißt, der Operator gibt eigentlich ein Ziel vor, wo der Manipulator hinfahren soll.
Shared Control?
Ja, geteilte Kontrolle. Und gewisse Freiheitsgrade seiner Bewegung werden eben vom Operator vorgegeben, zum Beispiel mit dem Bolzen senkrecht nach unten ins Loch reinzufahren. Das ist ein Kommando, das kommt vom Operator. Und das Ausregeln der entstehenden Momente und Querkräfte, das macht die Manipulatorsteuerung. Aufgrund der Sensorinformation von dem Sensor vorne an der Handwurzel. Und damit ist man schon mal in der Lage, ziemlich komplexe Dinge mit dem Manipulator zu tun.
Sind wir jetzt schon so ein bisschen in der Gegenwart, oder ist das schon auch noch so eine Erkenntnis dieser ersten Zeit gewesen?
Das ist eine Erkenntnis der ersten Zeit, die aber heute noch gilt. Also die Steuerungen laufen heute noch.
Aber wurde das dann auch schon so mit dem Computer gemacht? Also der Rückfluss an Informationen war dann auch da. Also man hat jetzt nicht nur mit dem Computer was gesteuert, sondern es ging dann auch wieder zurück und hat dann die Software beeinflusst.
Ja, richtig. Und man hat es auch stückweise, kam dann immer noch mehr dazu. Man hat dann festgestellt, okay, mit einem reinen Kraftmomentensensor kann ich zwar einen Großteil erledigen, aber es wäre auch schön, wenn der Manipulator zum Beispiel gut Entfernungen messen könnte. Das sind Dinge, die wir schlecht können. Wir können Entfernungen nur abschätzen. Es gibt Sensorsysteme für Manipulatoren, die können auf 100 Millimeter genauen Abstand zwischen einer Greiferspitze und der Oberfläche messen. Und diese Fähigkeiten kann man natürlich jetzt auch in der Robotostörung mit einbauen. Das heißt, man kann Dinge mit einem Manipulator machen, die der Mensch nicht einfach auf Anhieb so genau kann. Also genau zum Beispiel irgendwelche Entfernungen einstellen oder Geräte platzieren auf einem bestimmten Abstand.
Also machen die das dann optisch oder mit Ultraschall?
Wir haben hier ein Sensorsystem entwickelt und das muss man eigentlich sagen. Ich sage, wir haben diese ganzen Systeme hier im Institut selber entwickelt damals. Also Kraftmomentensensor, Entfernungssensor. Entfernungssensor ist ein Lasersystem, das auf dem Triangulationsprinzip basiert. Das heißt, man sendet einen Laserstrahl aus, der wird dann vom Objekt gegenüber reflektiert und kommt dann wieder auf ein Positionssensor zurück. Das ist so was ähnliches wie ein optisches Potentiometer. Auf dem Positionssensor wird dann ein Lichtfleck positioniert und die Position des Lichtflecks ist dann ein Maß für die Entfernung. Damit können wir sehr genau Entfernungen messen. Der Trick damals bei dem Sensor war, dass man auch das Umgebungslicht oder Änderungen der Umgebungsbeleuchtung mit ausgleicht. Oder zum Beispiel unterschiedliche Reflektionseigenschaften der Oberfläche, da konnte sich das System dadurch anpassen, dass die Sendeleistung der Laserdiode entsprechend der Reflektionseigenschaften geregelt wurde. Das heißt, man konnte über ein reflektierendes Teil fahren und nebenan einen dunklen Filz oder so was haben, da hat er trotzdem in etwa die gleiche Entfernung gemessen.
Das heißt, wenn das Material reflektiert, dann setzt man weniger Energie an? Und wenn das viel absorbiert, dann muss man halt entsprechend aufhalten.
Dann muss man auch mehr damit er noch nicht schlecht sieht. Aber am Anfang war eben das Problem, dass bei unterschiedlichen Reflektionseigenschaften halt auch unterschiedliche Entfernungen rauskamen. Einfach deswegen, weil der Lichtfleck, der auf dem PSD ankam, einfach zu groß wurde. Und eben durch die Reflektionseigenschaften wurden dann falsche Entfernungen gemessen. Und das haben wir dadurch in Griff bekommen, dass wir die Sendelleistung geregelt haben.
Befinden wir uns jetzt noch in den 70er Jahren, 80er Jahren?
Das war noch in den 80er Jahren, aber diese Sensoren verwenden wir auch heute noch. Und die wurden weiterentwickelt und wir setzen die Dinge sogar auch jetzt im Weltraum ein.
Was mich nur gerade interessiert hat, ist zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo war denn, gab es denn nur in Deutschland diese Entwicklung oder gab es auch schon andere Länder, die da entsprechend aktiv geworden sind?
Also wir haben damals keinen Kontakt gehabt zu irgendwelchen Institutionen im Ausland. Das war eben alles gegenüber Konferenzen. Dann hat man mitbekommen, was machen denn die anderen. Die Amerikaner hatten auch angefangen mit Kraftmomenten, geregelten Robotern. Aber da waren wir so eigentlich auf gleicher Augenhöhe mit denen. Und bei vielen Gebieten, meistens würde ich mal behaupten, sogar auch voraus.
Aber der Einsatz war jetzt eigentlich im Wesentlichen immer noch industrielle Anwendung. Das war sozusagen Standardmittelpunkt der Forschung.
Das waren industrielle Anwendungen, ja.
Hat ja dann auch relativ schnell zu Änderungen geführt, also in der Produktion, so 18er Jahre war ja auch der Zeitpunkt, glaube ich, wo das so langsam begann mit der Roboter-Automation beim Automobilbau.
Uns ging das eigentlich schon zu langsam. Wir hatten eigentlich gedacht, das müsste doch viel schneller funktionieren. Wir hatten viele Vertreter der Industrie da, die haben sich das angeguckt. Bei uns im Labor, was können wir denn machen? Zum Beispiel Lenkrad schneiden oder entkraten. Das war so eine Anwendung, die wir in die Industrie gebracht haben. Aber das hat einen riesen Anlaufbedarf, bis das endlich mal übernommen wurde. Und das geht eigentlich nur dadurch, dass das Industrieunternehmen feststellt, mit dem Manipulatorsystem kann ich Dinge schneller erledigen, als der Mensch das kann oder billiger erledigen. Darum, über diese Schiene kann man diese Technologie in die Industrie transferieren. Und wie gesagt, uns hat das eigentlich immer zu lange gedauert. Aber Anfang der 80er-Jahre sind so die ersten Systeme aufgetauchter Industrie, wo man versucht hat, Kraft geregelt oder mit Sensoren geregelt, irgendwelche Arbeiten in der Industrie, in der Montage zu erledigen. Wir haben zum Beispiel einen Sensor mal entwickelt, der in der Lage ist, Löcher in Blech zu orten. Das war ein magnetisches System, das hat in der Mitte eine Sendespule, außenrum vier Empfangsspulen. Und wenn ich jetzt über ein Blech fahre, das ein Loch hat, dann ergeben sich unterschiedliche Intensitäten im Fluss, in den einzelnen Empfängerspulen. Und damit kann ich mich schön über das Loch zentrieren. Und da gab es eine Anwendung, dass man diese Gummistopfen für die Hohlraumversiegelung bei den Autos, das wurden von Arbeitern nach der Hohlraumversiegelung in die Löcher reingedrückt. Und das haben wir mit einem Manipulator dann durchgeführt. Dazu haben wir einmal diesen magnetischen Sensor entwickelt und ein Werkzeug, das diese Gummistopfen anzaugt, mit Unterdruck und dann in diese gefundenen Löcher eindrückt. Das waren so die ersten Schritte, wo die Robotik in die Industrie reingekommen ist. Und inzwischen wird es natürlich an vielen Stellen verwendet.
Wann ist denn das Thema Raumfahrt dann das erste Mal akut geworden? Also ab welchem Zeitraum hat sich denn, ich weiß nicht, wer sich dafür wen interessiert hat, ob die Robotik ihre Möglichkeiten in die Raumfahrt getragen hat oder ob die Raumfahrt auch Bedarf angemeldet hat.
So ein Auslöser war damals die D1-Mission. Und man hat dann festgestellt, ja es wäre eigentlich gut, wenn man im Weltraum einen Manipulator hätte, der die Astronauten entlasten kann.
Also die D1-Mission ist eine Space Shuttle-Mission gewesen.
Eine Space Lab-Mission, eine deutsche Space Lab-Mission. Und dann gab es 1993 die D2-Mission. Und wir haben dann versucht, auf diese D2-Mission einen kleinen Manipulator hochzubekommen, um festzustellen, wie geht das überhaupt? Welche Probleme muss ich lösen, damit ich von der Erde aus einen Manipulator im Weltraum steuern kann? Wir hatten damals die Gelegenheit, auf die Columbia, die das Spacelab damals in den Weltraum transportiert hat, da hatten wir ein sogenanntes Rack bekommen, das ist so ein 19 Zoll Einschub, ein Arbeitsraum, in dem ein kleiner Manipulator platziert war, auch ein sechsgelenkiger Manipulator.
Also wenn wir jetzt von Manipulator sprechen, dann muss man sich so einen Roboterarm vorstellen.
Ja, ein Roboterarm mit einem Greifer vorne dran, mit so einem 2-Backen-Greifer, der irgendwas greifen kann und bewegen. Der Weg dorthin, wir haben Ende der 80er Jahre, ich glaube das war 1987, den Vorschlag gemacht, wir könnten doch bei der D2-Mission so ein Roboter fliegen. Bis man dann alle technischen Probleme gelöst hat, dann braucht man viele Jahre. Erstmal hat es geheißen, von der Erde aus Fernsteuern, das könnt ihr vergessen, das geht überhaupt nicht. Weil man kann keine schnellen Kommandos von der Erde aus in Weltraum schicken. Was man damals gemacht hat, auch bei D1-Mission, dass man viele Daten vom Spacelab runter übertragen hatte zur Erde, aber über Telemetrie-Kommunikation. Aber Kommandos nach oben wurden am Terminal eingetippt, um irgendwelche Geräte zu beeinflussen. Und wir wollten natürlich mit unserer damals schon lange erprobten Sensorkugel den Roboter oben im Weltraum direkt steuern. Dann sind wir an alle möglichen Grenzen gelaufen, alle Grenzen, die man sich vorstellen konnte, oder alle Türen, die waren zu. Das ging schon los.
Was ist denn die Datenmenge, die man da so benötigt, um das Ding halbwegs zu steuern?
Ja, das bewegt sich im Bereich von Kilobit pro Sekunde. Also wir hatten damals, um diesen sechsachsigen Manipulator zu steuern, ich glaube 64 Kilobit benötigt. Aber es gab keine...
Aber man kann ja auch langsamer steuern, oder? Also ich meine, ist die Geschwindigkeit jetzt so entscheidend?
Ja, ich kann es natürlich. Es gibt Konzepte, dass ich sage, ich gebe dem Manipulator überhaupt eine Position vor, die er erreichen soll. Und die sollte er dann selbstständig mit seiner Software, die er lokal vor Ort hat, auch erreichen können.
Aber das erfordert natürlich die Anforderungen an die...
Ja, dann muss er sich...
Dass die lokale Elektronik dann mehr leisten.
Richtig. Er muss seine Objekte selbstständig erkennen, sich dahin platzieren und so weiter. Und der erste Schritt war, einmal auszuloten, welche Technologien brauche ich denn, um online von der Erde zu steuern. Dass ich mich auch in einer Umgebung bewegen kann, die dem Robotersystem, sage ich mal, nicht 100 Prozent bekannt ist. Dazu kommt, dass man dann, wenn man diese Datenübertragung geschafft hat, ja auch Kommunikationswege hat in den Shuttle rein, die über Relais-Satelliten gehen. Das heißt, es addieren sich sehr hohe Latenzzeiten rein.
Und das Ganze dann sozusagen ursprünglich dann noch hier von Oberpfaffenhofen aus?
Das Ganze von Oberpfaffenhofen aus.
Das heißt, das musste auch erstmal in die USA?
Ja, das ging von hier, vom Kontrollzentrum über, ich glaube, Intelsat, rüber zu USA, dann über weiteren Satelliten nach White Sense, von White Sense zum... White Sense ist eine Bodenstation der Amerikaner. Von da aus werden Daten zu dem TDRS, Telemetry Data Relay Satellite, geschickt. Und der schickt die Daten runter zum Shuttle, weil der TDRS steht im geostationären Orbit. Schön mal draußen. Und wir haben damals die Computer in der ganzen Schleife zusammengezählt. Es waren etwa 25 Computer. Jeder hat die Datenpakete, die er von seinem Vorgänger empfangen hat, geprüft. Ist alles in Ordnung. Wenn es in Ordnung war, hat es zum Nächsten geschickt. Es waren also nicht die reinen Übertragungslaufzeiten über die Satellitenstrecken, sondern die Computer dazwischen, die die Hauptlatenzzeit erzeugen.
Ach wirklich?
Und ein Problem war eben, wie kann ich denn überhaupt?
Von welchem Jahr reden wir denn jetzt eigentlich?
Reden vom Jahr 1993. Also da fand diese Mission statt, aber die Vorbereitung hat natürlich so fünf, sechs Jahre vorher angefangen.
Das heißt, um jetzt ein Steuerkommando von hier dahin zu schicken, muss so ein Datenpaket erstmal durch 25 Hops, wenn man so schön sagt.
Richtig.
Und was war dann so die effektive Latenz bis dann mal?
Ja, wir haben gemessen, etwa 6 Sekunden.
6 Sekunden.
6 Sekunden Latenzzeit. Das Problem war ja aber erstmal, wie kriege ich denn die Daten überhaupt drauf? Wie gesagt, es gab ja damals Inputs nur über Terminals. Also ich hatte dann jemanden kennengelernt von der D1-Mission, ein Kollege aus Köln. Der hat mir erzählt, es gibt einen sogenannten Text-and-Graphics-Channel, mit dem man die Astronauten mit Informationen von der Erde versorgt. Da wurden Faxe nach oben in der Shuttle geschickt, zum Beispiel zu Timeline-Änderungen, Nachrichten von der Erde usw.
Also Timeline ist so ihr Einsatzplan.
Genau, ihr Einsatzplan. Wenn sich da was geändert hat, dann wurden es so einen Fax nach oben geschickt. Dann haben wir angefangen zu bohren, können wir diesen Kanal nicht nehmen, um damit unseren kleinen Roboter oben zu steuern. Die Idee war geboren, aber bis man das durchgesetzt hat, das hat viele, viele Besprechungen mit der NASA gekostet.
Man hätte ja auch einen Roboter bauen können, der dann diese Kommandos an der Tastatur einfach selber eingibt.
Dann hätte er wissen müssen, wo er drauf tippen muss. Und das hätte noch mehr Entwicklungsaufwand bedarf. Also wir reden immerhin von vor einigen Jahren. Okay, wir haben es dann geschafft, die NASA zu überzeugen, dass es auch kein Sicherheitsrisiko ist, wenn wir da 128 Kilobit hochschicken. Beziehungsweise wir haben von diesem Kanal nur etwa 64 Kilobit genutzt, um den Manipulator von der Erde auszusteuern. Das Problem war die Totzeit, also die Latenzzeit, sechs Sekunden. Wie kann man einen Manipulator steuern mit sechs Sekunden Totzeit? Ich stelle mir das immer so vor, wie wenn jemand im Auto sitzt, fährt durch eine Stadt mit viel Verkehr und dreht am Lenkrad und das Auto folgt erst sechs Sekunden später. Das bedarf einiger Übung, um da knitterfrei durch die Innenstadt zu kommen.
Allerdings.
Und wir haben das damals so gelöst, dass wir gesagt haben, wir simulieren alles das, was der Manipulator im Weltraum hat. Das heißt, wir haben eine Computer-Grafik entwickelt, auf der war der Manipulator selber vorhanden. Und es waren alle Objekte in seinem Arbeitsraum vorhanden als Grafik. Jetzt konnte man mit der Sensorkugel diesen simulierten Roboter in der Computer-Grafik direkt bewegen. Also der hat sofort reagiert, wenn ich auf diese Kugel gedrückt habe, hat der Manipulator diese Arbeit ausgeführt. Und diese Bewegungskommandos hat man gleichzeitig zum Shuttle hochgeschickt, zu dem Rotex-Manipulator.
Wo dann die Realität sechs Sekunden später versucht hat, der virtuellen Simulation da zu folgen.
Genau, nach der halben Laufzeit, etwa nach drei Sekunden, kamen die Kommandos oben beim Roboter an. Da hat die Bewegung ausgeführt. Da wurde oben an Bord wieder der erreichte Gelenkwinkel gemessen. Dieser Gelenkwinkel wurde wieder über Datenübertragung nach unten geschickt. Und den haben wir auf der Bodenstation bei uns in der Computer-Grafik auch angezeigt. Das heißt, in dieser Grafik hatten wir zwei Roboter-Systeme, die wir sehen konnten, zwei Arme. Einen, den man direkt fernsteuert. Und der zweite, das war so ein Drahtgitter-Modell, der hat die Position dargestellt, die der reale Manipulator im Weltraum hatte.
Und dann ging es sozusagen darum, dass diese beiden Werte nicht voneinander abwichen?
Genau, man hat ein Nachlaufen gesehen aufgrund der Latenzzeit. Also wenn ich ein Bewegungskommando vorgegeben habe, dann konnte ich genau sehen, wie der reale Manipulator hinterherläuft. Und man hat dann natürlich versucht, Unstimmigkeiten zwischen der Computersimulation und der realen Welt wieder mit Sensorsignalverarbeitung auszugleichen. Weil wenn ein Objekt nicht genau an der Position sitzt, in Realität, an der es in der Computer-Grafik angezeigt wird, dann ergeben sich hier rein dadurch, wenn ich den Greifer schließe, irgendwelche Kräfte oder Drehmomente. Und die muss man natürlich ausregeln.
Weil sozusagen etwas nicht da ist, was man haben will, oder auf einmal etwas im Wesens, was man nicht klar hat.
Genau, das ist ein paar Millimeter versetzt. Also ich greife jetzt irgendein Objekt, das sitzt ein paar Millimeter neben der Position, wie ich es in der Computer-Grafik habe. Wenn ich jetzt keine lokale Regelung hätte, an dem Roboter oben im Weltraum, dann würden dadurch natürlich große Kräfte entstehen, wenn ich einfach an der falschen Position den Greifer schließe. Und diese Kräfte, die wurden wieder gemessen in dem Kraftmomentensensor oben am Manipulator und der Regelkreis oben an Bord direkt geschlossen. Das heißt, der hat sofort auf seine eigenen Sensorinformationen reagiert.
Und damit... Was war denn das eigentliche Setup da oben? Also da war halt dieser Roboterarm. Der war dann so umgeben von Dreiecken und Kugeln und...
Ja, so ähnlich. Der war erstmal eingesperrt in einer Arbeitszelle, dass er nicht raus kann. Da gab es ein kleines Fenster, dass die Astronauten reingucken. Jaja, man muss ja alle Sicherheitsbedingungen erfüllen. Wir mussten jede Menge Nachweise erbringen, dass wir das Shuttle nicht zerstören. Also der Space Lab, dass der Manipulator nicht aus seiner Zelle raus kann.
Und so ein Eigenleben entwickelt.
Ja, das muss man natürlich alle möglichen Tests nachweisen, dass das alles funktioniert. Er hatte da drin Objekte, die man umsetzen kann. Das waren einfach so Bajonettverschlüsse, mit denen man ein Objekt löst von seiner Halterung. Kann es dann an einem anderen Ort in seinem Arbeitsraum wieder einsetzen. Das ging einfach nur darum, so prototypisch zu demonstrieren. Ich kann mit einem Manipulator, wenn ich ihn von der Erde ausstöre, doch recht komplexe Vorgänge im Weltraum erledigen. Dann gab es Fügevorgänge, wo man Würfelstrukturen zusammengesetzt hat. Da waren an jedem Würfel zwei kleine Bolzen, die beim gegenüberliegenden Würfelwitter in die entsprechenden Löcher eingeführt werden mussten. Das Ganze geht natürlich alles nur kraftgeregelt, damit man das sauber platzieren kann. Wenn man da einen Millimeter Versatz hat, dann würden sich diese beiden Bolzen natürlich sofort verklemmen. Das hat alles die lokale Regelung im Spacelab an der Manipulator-Steuerung ausregeln müssen.
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen, was ist denn der große Unterschied? Das Offensichtliche ist natürlich der Mangel an aktiver einwirkender Schwerkraft. Das heißt, das ist ja erstmal der offensichtliche Unterschied. Welchen Einfluss hat das jetzt tatsächlich gehabt? Was hat man bei diesen Experimenten festgestellt?
Gibt es noch andere Dinge, die dort einen Unterschied gemacht haben? Man kann den Manipulator, so wie wir ihn hier auf der Erde einsetzen, nicht einfach nehmen und da oben ins Shuttle setzen. Man muss nachweisen, dass aus der Elektronik, aus den Schmiermitteln und all den Dingen, die man da hochbringt, keine giftigen Gase rauskommen. Man muss einen Ausgasungstest bestehen. Da gibt es ganz bestimmte Regeln, die man einfach erfüllen muss. Diese Tests muss man nachweisen, sonst wird man nicht mit nach oben genommen. Das bedingt natürlich auch, dass das System auch den Start überstehen muss. Während des Starts entstehen relativ hohe Vibrationen auf das System. Das heißt, bevor wir den Manipulator nach oben geschickt haben, wurde der hier auf einen Rütteltisch gesetzt und in allen Raumachsen angeregt. Um zu gucken, gibt es irgendwelche Eigenschwingungen, die dazu führen, dass sich zum Beispiel Schrauben öffnen während des Starts. Es klingt seltsam, aber ich habe es selber gesehen, dass Schrauben, die nicht gesichert sind mit einem Kleber, sich durch die Vibration langsam aufdrehen. Wenn man das so baut, wie man es normalerweise auf der Erde verwendet, dann muss man nur lange genug rütteln und schütteln, und dann kann man die Einzelteile zusammenkehren. Man musste konstruktiv dafür sorgen, dass man diesen Start überlebt. Zum anderen gibt es noch ein Problem der Wärmeabfuhr. Denn im Weltraum gibt es keine Schwerkraft. Das heißt, ich erzeug jetzt mit jedem Computer, der da oben in den Gelenken arbeitet, Wärme. Die Wärme bleibt da, wo sie erzeugt wird. Wir haben da oben Atmosphäre. Das war ja im Spacelab selber. Aber die warme Luft steigt nicht nach oben, weil eben die Schwerkraft fehlt. Jetzt muss man dafür sorgen, dass die irgendwie abtransportiert wird. Das geht im Innenleben.
Diese Konvektion ist es eigentlich.
Die Konvektionskühlung fehlt.
Kerzen brennen rund und so.
Oder ich schalte einen Tauchseeder ein und habe eine glühende Luftkugel um den Tauchseeder herum. Irgendwann will ich nichts tun. Das haben wir auch erprobt. Wir haben damals einen Greifer oben gehabt, mit dem wir die Objekte gegriffen haben. Wir hatten auch einen Experimentteil, um festzustellen, stimmen unsere Thermalrechnungen, die wir vorher durchführen mussten, mit der Realität überein. Wenn ich den Greifer so stark belaste, wird entsprechend viel Energie in den Antrieben umgesetzt. Wie weit heizt er sich dadurch auf? Dadurch wurde der Ventilator in der Arbeitszelle ausgeschaltet. Wir haben einige Greifversuche gemacht und geguckt, ob der Temperaturanstieg etwa dem entspricht, wie wir es vorher voraussimuliert haben. Das war für uns natürlich wichtig, weil wir in Zukunft wieder Komponenten in den Weltraum schicken wollen. Dazu ist es notwendig, dass ich das Thermalverhalten des Systems vorher simulieren kann. Das heißt, wenn man so ein System konstruiert, einen Greifer oder einen ganzen Roboterarm, dann muss man sich sehr wohl überlegen, wo kommt die Energie denn hin? Wie transportiere ich die weg? Und das ist im Innenleben, in der Raumstation oder im Spacelab noch relativ einfach, weil da habe ich ja eine Atmosphäre. Im Prinzip kann ich mit Ventilatoren arbeiten, um die Wärme wegzubringen. Viel kritischer wird das Ganze, wenn man in freiem Weltraum rausgeht. Dann fehlt nicht nur die Schwerkraft, sondern auch das Medium Luft. Und ich muss irgendwie die Wärme, die erzeugt, entweder aktiv kühlen, das ist aber relativ teuer und aufwendig. Man kann da Pellierelemente zum Beispiel nehmen, um die Wärme wieder wegzubringen. Aber der gängige Weg ist, man versucht, die entstandene Wärme an die Außenhaut zu transportieren und die Außenfläche so zu gestalten, dass möglichst viel Energie in Weltraum abgestrahlt werden kann, ohne viel Energie von der Sonne aufzunehmen. Das ist nämlich der Spagat, den man dabei machen muss.
Weil man ja sozusagen auch draußen ist und da scheint die Sonne dann wieder ungehindert auf das Objekt.
Richtig, wenn ich das Ding einfach schwarz anstreiche, dann kann ich zwar sehr gut wärmer abstrahlen, aber ich nehme auch sehr gut wärmer auf, wenn die Sonne scheint. Und man hat ja immer damit zu tun, dass ich meistens von einer Seite Sonneneinstrahlung habe und auf der anderen Seite Schatten. Dadurch ergeben sich natürlich wieder auch Verspannungen in den Gelenken. Man muss sich vorstellen, wenn ich auf der einen Seite 80, 90 Grad plus und auf der anderen Seite 20 Grad minus habe oder weniger noch, dann würde das dazu führen, dass jedes gängige Getriebe, was man so kennt, anfängt schwer gängig zu werden. Und das muss man konstruktiv in den Griff bekommen.
Also weil es sich einfach durch die Ausdehnung dann verklemmt.
Es verklemmt sich, ja. Man muss versuchen, möglichst gut wärmeleitende Materialien zu verwenden, sodass der Temperaturgradient von einer Seite zu anderen möglichst gering wird. Und zum anderen auch dafür sorgen, dass, ich sag mal, in Betriebe auch etwas eifermig werden darf, ohne dass es klemmt. Und mit diesen Methoden schafft man das dann.
Aber es ist natürlich knifflig, mit so hohen Toleranzen zu arbeiten, wo man jetzt eigentlich ein Gerät bauen will, was ja dadurch besticht, dass es eben eigentlich niedrige Toleranzen hat.
Ja, richtig. Aber man bekommt es nicht anders hin. Wenn man feinfühlig arbeiten will, dann muss ich, wie du selber sagst, Geräte bauen, die sehr genau funktionieren, die möglichst wenig Getriebespiel haben und so weiter. Also man kämpft da eigentlich gegen die eigenen Anforderungen. Ich möchte kein Getriebespiel, andererseits darf ich die Lage aber auch nicht so eng einstellen, dass sie bei kleinen Temperaturunterschieden schon zu verklemmen neigen. Und das ist genau das, wo wir uns hier seit vielen Jahren beschäftigen. Wie muss man diese Dinge konstruieren, damit sie überhaupt eine Chance haben zu funktionieren? Der andere Effekt ist ja noch neben dem Thermalproblem, ist auch die radioaktive Strahlung, mit der man im Weltraum zu kämpfen hat. Es gibt ja die Möglichkeit, dass durch Protonenbeschuss zum Beispiel ein Prozessor getroffen wird und er würde dann sofort abbrennen, indem auf der Struktur zwischen den Leiterbahnen im Chip ein Kurzschluss entsteht und dadurch ist das Ding zerstört. Wir haben dafür Methoden entwickelt, wie man das verhindern kann. Wir haben sogenannte Latch-up-Schutzschaltungen entwickelt. Man nennt das Latch-up, wenn ein Teil von so einem Proton getroffen wird. Diese Schutzschaltungen messen den Strom, den der Computer oder der Memory-Chip zieht. Wenn ein drastischer Anstieg festgestellt wird aufgrund dieses Kurzschlusses, dann muss blitzschnell die Stromversorgung abgeschaltet werden. Das ist das Erste, was man tun muss. Das reicht aber noch nicht aus, weil meistens auf den Schaltungen in den Kondensatoren und Induktivitäten so viel Energie gespeichert ist, die ausreichen würde, um den Prozessor trotzdem zu zerstören. Was da neu dazugekommen ist bei uns, ist, dass wir dann, nachdem die Stromversorgung abgeschaltet wurde, auch ein Kurzschluss aktiv erzeugt wird vor diesem zu schützenden Bauteil. Das heißt, man schließt es noch mal kurz, sodass die gespeicherte Ladung in diesem Kurzschluss vernichtet wird und nicht in diese Elektronik komponiert wird.
Das heißt, alle Kondensatoren werden entladen?
Die werden alle blitzschnell entladen. Kein Strom mehr. Das Ganze passiert in etwa zwei Millisekunden, dann ist der Spuk vorbei und das System fährt wieder hoch und kann seine Arbeit wieder aufnehmen. Aber um da hinzukommen, diese Entwicklung, das hat relativ lange gedauert. Erstmal muss man die Effekte kennenlernen. Womit haben wir es denn überhaupt zu tun? Da haben wir nach Rotex 1993 versucht, eine Hardware zu gestalten. Rotex, das hieß Roboter Technologie Experiment. Das war in diesem Experiment auf dem Spacelab damals. Auf der D2-Mission.
Bei D1 gab es noch überhaupt keine Robotik? Das wollen wir zusammenfassen. Man wollte das allererste Mal einen Roboter im Weltall betreiben. War das jetzt wirklich der erste? Ja, das war weltweit der erste. Jetzt gibt es allerlei Dinge, die anders sind. Man hat den Start, das Ding muss rütteln, die Vibrationen aushalten. Man muss gut bauen und aufpassen, dass die Schrauben nicht abhauen. Dann hat man dieses Thermikproblem, das man dadurch löst, dass man gut leitende Materialien hat, dass die Wärme sich innerhalb des Gerätes selber so fein verteilt, dass es kein Problem darstellt. Aber sie entschwindet schon, nur nicht so schnell und nicht so effizient, wie das hier auf der Erde der Fall ist.
Sie entschwindet zum Beispiel durch aktive Kühlung mit Ventilatoren im Spacelab oder in der Raumstation. Man muss die fehlende Schwerkraft dadurch ersetzen, dass sie aktiv über ein Ventilator kühlt und damit die Wärme abtransportiert.
Und Radioaktivität generell? Ist das auch schon ein Problem im Spacelab gewesen? Oder ist das jetzt eigentlich nur, wenn man draußen ist?
Natürlich gibt es auch im Spacelab erhöhte Radioaktivität. Aber das war damals wesentlich geringer, als wenn man direkt im Freien arbeiten will. Das ist nochmal eine Klasse schwieriger.
Aber im Prinzip wurde das jetzt auch schon dort berücksichtigt?
Damals noch nicht. Bei Rotex haben wir das nicht berücksichtigt. Das kommt später.
Aber das war dann so eine der Erkenntnisse, dass man das dann mal besser berücksichtigen sollte, weil es halt Ausfälle gab.
Ja, wir hatten keine richtigen Ausfälle, aber uns war bewusst, wenn man aus dem Spacelab oder aus dem Modul rausgeht in den freien Weltraum, dann müssen wir noch ganz andere Methoden anwenden, um mit den Problemen zurechtzukommen.
Und was ist jetzt mit der Schwerkraft selber? Also, ich meine, dem Mangel derselben. Hat das denn eigentlich irgendeine konkrete konstruktive Auswirkung, oder ist das dem Roboter eigentlich weitgehend egal geworden?
Das ist eigentlich egal. Er hat sogar, ihm wird's leichter. Er muss seinen Arm nicht selber halten. Da muss ihn nur beschleunigen, wenn er eine Bewegung ausführt. Also insofern...
Muss er es in der Sensorik berücksichtigen, dass sozusagen die Verhältnisse anders sind?
Die Sensorik, die Kraftmomentensensorik, die wird einmal nach dem Einschalten genullt. Und ab da spürt sie alle Kräfte, die extern auf sie einwerken. Also hier auf der Erde muss ich eine Schwerkraftkompensation machen. Das heißt, wenn ich die Orientierung des Arms ändere und möchte da wieder feinfühlig etwas einfügen, Kraftmomenten geregelt, muss ich den Einfluss der Schwerkraft rausrechnen. Das brauch ich im Weltraum nicht. Und insofern wird es eigentlich leichter, weil ich diesen Effekt der Schwerkraft im Weltraum nicht berücksichtigen muss. Ich muss mich nur mit der Beschleunigung von dem Arm selber oder den gegriffenen Objekten befassen.
Und gab es noch eine andere Größe, die da noch mit reinkam, die noch Probleme gemacht hat außer dem Start, der Radioaktivität und der Wärme?
Ja, die Sicherheitsbedingungen, die man einfach nachweisen muss. Man muss nachweisen, es kann nichts abbrechen. Man muss finite Elemente Rechnung machen, um nachzuweisen, die Konstruktion, die wir hier abgeliefert haben, die es so stabil sind, dass durch Belastung nichts abbrechen kann. Und Belastung heißt dann, das sind Maßstäbe, die angelegt werden. Die liegen weit über dem, was der Manipulator eigentlich überhaupt erledigen muss. Da sind Sicherheitsfaktoren drauf gerechnet. Insofern muss man dann viele Bedingungen erfüllen, bevor die NASA Ja sagt und den Roboter mit ins Spacelab mit nach oben nimmt. Das mussten wir alles nachweisen. Und vor allen Dingen auch, wie ich vorher erklärt habe, die Probleme mit der Datenübertragung. Das war für uns der größte Punkt, wo wir am längsten gekämpft haben.
Aber das hat dann am Ende funktioniert.
Das hat hervorragend funktioniert. Und zwar war das auch so, dass wir vorher niemals richtig testen konnten. Wir schließen ja einen Kreis. Wir steuern vom Boden aus einen Manipulator im Weltraum. Und wir möchten gerne sehen, aufgrund der Eingabekommandos, was macht denn das Manipulatorsystem? Heutzutage ist man gewohnt, man macht so einen integrierten Systemtest. Das sind alle Komponenten beieinander. Man setzt sich mal hin, gibt seine Kommandos. Und das System, was nachher im Weltraum ist, reagiert schon. Diese Testmöglichkeiten hatten wir damals nicht. Wir haben das so getestet, dass wir der NASA Datensätze geschickt haben über einen Link vom Kontrollzentrum hier aus, von Oberpfaffenhofen. Das waren Daten, die wir von einer Sensorkugel aufgezeichnet haben. Mit der wollten wir den Manipulator steuern. Diese Daten wurden rüber nach Houston geschickt. Die Amerikaner haben die ausgeplottet und haben uns das als Fax wieder zurückgeschickt. Und wir haben dann die vielen Zahlen verglichen, ob da Übertragungsfehler waren. Wir hatten also nicht die Möglichkeit, bevor wir den Manipulator im Spacelab in Betrieb nehmen, das Ding einmal richtig zu testen. Wir haben Tests gemacht hier in Friedrichshafen. Damals hieß die Firma noch Dornier, heute IADS. Da hat man den Manipulator auf die Seite gelegt, weil er konnte sein eigenes Gewicht nicht heben von den Antrieben her unter Schwerkraft. Das heißt, man hat ihn auf die Seite gelegt und mit Gegengewichten einen Gewichtsausgleich geschaffen, sodass man gewisse Bewegungsprinzipien einfach überprüfen konnte. Das war eine Überprüfung, die konnten wir durchführen. Wir wussten also, dass der Manipulator geht.
Ich verstehe, der Roboter war auch so gebaut, dass er nur im All funktionieren konnte eigentlich so.
Das konnte man testen, aber wir konnten nicht den gesamten Weg der Datenübertragung mittesten. Das war der spannende Moment, als das Shuttle oben war und wir das erste Mal Rotex eingeschaltet haben. Und ich kann mich gut erinnern, ich bin damals an der Sensorkugel gesessen und habe so ein erstes vorsichtiges Bewegungskommando gegeben. Und wenn man dann auf die Antwort wartet, dann sind sechs Sekunden elend lang. Ich bin da gesessen und hab gesagt, da funktioniert ja doch nicht. Und es war ziemlich kompliziert damals auch, die ganze Methode der Datenübertragung zu programmieren.
Der Adrenalin-Kick, den man kriegt, wenn die Daten dann wirklich zurückkommen, der durfte ja auch nicht unerheblich gewesen sein.
Ja, das war natürlich ein tolles Erlebnis, als ich gesehen habe, der fährt dorthin und er fährt auch dahin, wo er eigentlich hinfahren sollte. Und das war für mich so ein Art Erlebnis, nur ein kleiner Schritt, aber ein Riesenschritt für die Menschheit, das war so für die Weltraum-Robotik. Das war nur eine ganz kleine Bewegung, aber wir wussten alle, damit funktioniert das Prinzip. Und wir sind dann einfach durch die einzelnen Experimente durchgegangen, so wie wir es vorher über Jahre hier im Labor geprobt haben. Und es war kein Unterschied festzustellen, ob ich jetzt so ein Objekt oben im Weltraum greife und umsetze auf einen anderen Ort. Kraftmomenten geregelt. Das ist genauso abgelaufen, wie wir es vorher über die vielen Jahre hier im Labor erprobt haben. Das einzige Experiment, das wir nicht richtig proben konnten, das war so die Kür damals, wir wollten versuchen, einen kleinen, frei fliegenden Würfel automatisch einzufangen.
Automatisch, das heißt, der Roboter macht alles komplett lokal selber?
Richtig, der Roboter macht alles erstmal selber. Er versucht in einem Videobild diesen kleinen, frei fliegenden Würfel zu erkennen. Er versucht, die Bewegung dieses Würfels zu erfassen und vorauszuberechnen. Und muss dann selber sich so hinbewegen, dass er das Ding auch im richtigen Zeitpunkt greift. Das Problem dabei war aber nur, dass wir oben im Spacelab keinen Hochleistungsrechner hatten, so wie man das heute kennt, der entsprechende Bildverarbeitung machen konnte. Das ganze Robotersystem, kann man vielleicht noch erwähnen, lief damals auf einem 8086. Das ist ein Rechner, den kennt heute gar niemand mehr.
Na ja, das ist das, womit der PC mal angefangen hat.
Ja, genau. Der hatte eine Taktfrequenz von sage und schreibe 5 MHz. Im Gegensatz zu einigen Gigahertz, was man heute so hat in der CPU. Und hatte nebenan einen 8087 Prozessor, das war ein Floating Point Prozessor. Mit diesen beiden Systemen lief die ganze Regelung ab. Also Sensorwerte einlesen, durchrechnen, welchen Einfluss hat es auf die Gelenkwinkel und die Gelenkwinkelanstörung durchzuführen. Und das lief damals. Alle 50 Millisekunden wurde damals eine Regelschleife durchgerechnet. Und damit war man aber schon in der Lage, relativ komplexe Fügevorgänger oder sowas auszuregeln mit Manipulatoren.
Und hat das Ding dann in Würfel gefangen?
Das hat in Würfel auch gefangen, aber der Aufwand dabei, der war natürlich riesengroß, weil wir haben, dadurch, dass wir oben keinen Bildverarbeitungsrechner hatten, haben wir die Videobilder zur Erde runter telemetriert. Und im Kontrollraum stand ein Rechner, der hat die Bildverarbeitung durchgeführt. Das heißt, da wurde das Objekt erkannt, getreckt und die Bewegung voraus berechnet. Das ist jetzt im Weltraum...
Da muss aber dann die Bewegung ja für die gesamte Latenz der Hin- und Zurückübertragung, also 6 Sekunden, noch mal ein bisschen spielen.
Genau, das war das Problem. Wir mussten genau wissen, wie ist die aktuelle Latenzzeit.
Wie viele Sekunden musste da voraus gesehen werden?
Also die gesamte Latenzzeit war 6 Sekunden. Und man rechnet das ja jetzt an einem Ort. Das heißt, ich muss immer die 6 Sekunden berücksichtigen.
Das heißt, man hat so Bild für Bild für Bild, dann merkt man so, der rotiert sich so und bewegt sich so und so in die Richtung. Das heißt, in 6 Sekunden müsste er dann wahrscheinlich in dieser Position da und da sein. Dann musste man den Roboter entsprechend, der ja dann, ich weiß nicht, wie schnell konnte der sich bewegen, also wie schnell war der? Der dürfte ja auch jetzt nicht so super fix gerechnet sein.
Nee, der konnte schon relativ fix fahren. Also so ein paar Zentimeter pro Sekunde hat er leicht geschafft. Der Roboter war nicht langsam. Der ist in der Lage, dem...
Wie groß war der? Was hat der für so ein Radius? War das jetzt wie so ein Arm?
Das ist echt vergleichbar mit dem menschlichen Arm.
Okay, aber ein paar Zentimeter pro Sekunde, also wenn der Würfel irgendwie abhaut, dann ist das ja schon so ein gewisses Rennen.
Ja, aber die Bewegung, die da oben stattgefunden hat mit dem Würfel, die war ja auch nicht so, wie wenn man jetzt einen Tennisball durch die Gegend wirft. Und zwar haben wir das ja auch vorsichtig angefangen. Es konnte uns keiner sagen, was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn wir diesen Würfel mit dem Greifer frei geben. Es hätte ja sein können, dass er einfach an einer Greiferbacke hängen bleibt und da mitfährt. Ich muss ihn wegschütteln. Ich hab das Experiment damals gesteuert und hab den Würfel ganz vorsichtig losgelassen. Und er hat sich tatsächlich von den Greiferbacken gelöst und ist vor dem Greifer gestanden. Still im Raum gestanden. Dann haben wir versucht, jetzt probieren wir doch einfach mal zuzugreifen. Ich hab dann den Arm ein Stück zurückgezogen. Dann haben wir diesen Automatismus angeworfen. Also Position-Trecken dieses Würfels. Und die Automatiksteuerung wurde dann eingeschaltet, sodass der Manipulator sich selber zu dem Würfel hinbewegt und automatisch auch zugreift. Und während dieses Vorgangs gab es ein kleines Missverständnis zwischen dem Bildverarbeitungsoperator und mir. Da hat mir zugerufen, wir haben diesen kleinen Würfel nicht mehr getreckt, wir haben ihn verloren. Da hatte ich einen Greifer öffnen und ein Kommando losgelassen aufgrund dieser Information. Und es passierte folgendes. Wir sind eigentlich richtig hingefahren. Wir hatten dieses Objekt richtig getreckt. Und wir haben es auch kurzzeitig gegriffen. Aber nach dem Greifen kam sofort mein Greifer öffnen, ein Kommando oben an. Und da wurde der Greifer geöffnet und das Objekt freigegeben. Und zwar aus einer Bewegung raus. Weil wir sind ja vorher mit dem Manipulator zu dem Ding hingefahren. Zugegriffen, einmal kurz zu und wieder auf. Das heißt, wir haben den kleinen Würfel angekickt. Und dann wurde es richtig spannend, weil wir wussten nicht, wo fliegt der jetzt hin. Und wir hatten vorne am Greifer...
Ich meine, war da jetzt noch mal so ein Pixi-Glas drumherum?
Ja, der Manipulator war in so einer Arbeitszelle, in so einer Box drin. Der Würfel konnte aus der Box nicht raus. Aber man musste ihn wieder finden. Und wir hatten vorne am Greifer eine Stereokamera. Und ich habe jetzt mit der Hand durch Bewegung des Manipulators in der Arbeitszelle rumgesucht. Wo fliegt denn das Ding überhaupt rum? Und irgendwann hat man ihn wieder im Bild. Da kam er so schräg von der Seite unten hoch. Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, jetzt schalten wir die Automatik ein und niemand greift mehr ein. Wir lassen das einfach mal laufen. Und das war eigentlich so ein relativ kritischer Fall. Der Würfel ist gar nicht so langsam geflogen und auch relativ nah an der Wand. Das heißt, man hat nicht beliebig viele Möglichkeiten. Wo greift man den an? Ja, und dann haben wir es einfach gestartet. Und das hat auf Anhieb funktioniert.
Und er hat den einfach wieder selber eingefangen.
Ja, er hat den selbstständig eingefangen. Und das ist ein prototypisches Experiment. Wie kann ich zum Beispiel Satelliten einfangen oder irgendwelche Teile, die im Weltraum rumschwirren? Weil das ist jetzt das Ziel. Da wollen wir eigentlich hin mit unserer ganzen Robotik-Entwicklung. Und das hat bisher, glaube ich, auch noch niemand nachgemacht, dass man freifliegende Teile im Weltraum mit einem Manipulator einfängt.
Ach echt? Obwohl das jetzt das allererste Experiment überhaupt war?
Das war das allererste Experiment. Und ich kenne kein Experiment, wo das wiederholt wurde bis jetzt.
Aber trotzdem ist ja jetzt Robotik durchaus verbreitet. Also an den Raumstationen, insbesondere an der ISS, finden sich ja entsprechende Geräte.
Da findet man viele Geräte, wovon wir immer sagen, die verhalten sich wie ein Kran. Das sind Geräte, da kann ich Lasten damit transportieren. Und die sind rein positionsgeregelt. Also man gibt denen irgendwelche Positionen an, die fahren die an und können dann zum Beispiel irgendwelche Module aus dem Shuttle rausnehmen und an die Raumstation hin transportieren, sodass sie da montiert werden. Was wir unter Roboter verstehen, sind Systeme, die sich mehr menschenähnlich verhalten. Das heißt, wir haben Sensoren drin, um zum Beispiel in jedem Gelenkabtrieb das erzeugte Drehmoment zu messen. Das ist ein Drehmomentensensor, der in jedem Getriebeausgang drin sitzt. Wenn man das jetzt bei sechs oder sieben Gelenken integriert, können diese Drehmomentensensoren natürlich auch spüren, wenn von außen jemand gegen diesen Arm drückt. Das heißt, wenn ich gegen einen Manipulator-Arm von uns zum Beispiel gegen den Ellbogen drücke, dann spürt er das und er kann mir ausweichen. Wir wollen mit unserem Robotersystem zusammen mit dem Menschen arbeiten. Und das schafft man nur, indem sich der Arm auch sehr menschenähnlich verhält. Einmal von seinen Bewegungsmöglichkeiten. Da geht es eben nicht mehr genau nur mit sechs Achsen. Da kann ich immer nur einen Punkt im Raum mit einer ganz bestimmten Gelenkstellung erreichen, sondern wir bauen Systeme, die sind kinematisch redundant, das heißt, sie haben mindestens sieben Gelenke. Damit kann ich dann zum Beispiel solche Dinge machen, dass ich mit dem Greifer einen festen Punkt im Raum anfahre, den halte und ihm gleichzeitig den Ellbogen wegdrücke. Und er wird trotzdem seinen angefahrenen Punkt im Raum stabil halten. Das ist das, was wir relativ schwer können. Aber der Manipulator kann das sehr gut.
Wie viele Achsen haben wir denn so im Arm? Lass mal so, können wir das vergleichen überhaupt?
Ja, mehr als acht Freiheitsgrade. Ich kann es jetzt nicht genau sagen. Aber bereits mit sieben Gelenken im Roboter kann man das redundante Gelenk dazu verwenden, um andere Armorientierungen einzustellen, um zum Beispiel einen bestimmten Punkt zu erreichen.
Weil es mehrere Antworten gibt auf diese Frage.
Oder ich kann die sogenannten Singulärstellen umgehen. Wenn ich den Ellbogen und die Hand alles in einer Achse habe, dann gibt es ja mathematisch viele Möglichkeiten, wie man dann den Punkt anfangen kann. Das umgeht man dadurch, dass man einfach diesen Ellbogen niemals zum Beispiel gerade durchträgt. Sondern man macht dann Bewegungen, die diese Singularität umgehen. Oder man nimmt diesen zusätzlichen Freiheitsgrad her, um die Bewegung zu optimieren, Energie einzusparen. Oder möglichst wenig sich zu bewegen, möglichst schnell diesen Ort zu erreichen. Und mit diesen, ich sag mal, menschenähnlichen Verhalten werden diese Arme auch von den Menschen akzeptiert. Also wenn ich mir vorstelle, ich sollte mit einem starken Industrieroboter, mit einem sehr steifen System zusammen irgendwelche Montagen durchführen, dann hätte ich Schweißperlen auf der Stirn. Die Systeme bei uns, mit denen kann man zusammenarbeiten. Und wenn die irgendwo anstoßen, dann können die das merken, bleiben selbstständig stehen, je nachdem, was man programmiert hat. Man kann das so einstellen, dass wenn plötzlich unerwartete Kräfte auftreten, dann stoppt der Manipulator. Oder wir haben auch Versuche durchgeführt, wo man einen Manipulator gegen den Menschen fahren lässt. Und sobald er den Stoß feststellt, versucht er sofort dagegen zu regeln. Und man kann dadurch erreichen, dass keine Verletzungen entstehen. Also die Dinge sind von Haus aus einmal so sicher gebaut, dass sie auch niemanden verletzen, wenn man mit ihm zusammenarbeitet. Das ist ein entscheidender Faktor, weil sonst würden sie niemals einen Menschen finden, der direkt mit einem Manipulator zusammenarbeitet. Und diese Systeme, die sind natürlich wesentlich komplexer von ihrem Aufbau her, von der Regelung, die in den Gelenkmodulen stattfindet. Wir haben das so gelöst, dass jedes Gelenk besteht im Prinzip aus den gleichen Komponenten. Die sind gleich aufgebaut. Wir haben einen Regler drin, also eine Elektronik. Wir haben die Motoren und die Getriebe. Das ist alles eine Gelenkeinheit. Und diese Gelenkregler, den kann man so programmieren, dass man entweder rein positionsgeregelt fahren kann. Das heißt, ich stell den mal auf 15,3 Grad, dann fährt er das an und hält diese Position. Die andere Methode ist, dass man sagt, man gibt einen Drehmoment vor. Das heißt, er bewegt sich so lange, bis er seinen Gegenmoment erreicht hat, dann bleibt er stehen. Und es gibt eine Kombination zwischen beiden.
Also zum Beispiel das Schließen der Greifzange wäre so eine Bewegung?
Ja, das Schließen der Greifzange ist so eine Bewegung. Oder ich möchte zum Beispiel mit einem Manipulator eine Tür aufmachen. Dann kann ich sagen, zieh so lange an der Tür, bis du ein gewisses Gegenmoment spürst. Dann hast du den Anschlag erreicht, bleib stehen. Die andere Methode ist, dass man beides kombiniert. Die Positionsregelung und die Drehmomentenregelung. Dann kann ich im Prinzip eine Feder programmieren. Der fährt auf die vorgegebene Position. Ich kann ihn aber aus dieser Position wegdrücken, wenn ich ein entsprechendes Gegenmoment aufbringe. Wenn ich die Kraft wieder wegnehme, fährt er in seine vorgegebene Position. Diese Regelungstechniken sind bei den Manipulatoren, wie sie jetzt auf der Raumstation oder im Shuttle betrieben werden, natürlich nicht drin. Die sind rein positionsgeregelt. Damit lassen sich viele Dinge nicht so effektiv durchführen, wie wir es zum Beispiel mit einem relativ komplexen Manipulator tun können. Dieser Manipulator kann ja ohne, dass er jetzt noch mal externe Sensorik bekommt, dadurch, dass er in jedem Gelenk seine Drehmomente misst, weiß er auch, welche Kräfte er an der Greiferspitze gegen seine Umgebung übt. Das sieht so aus, weil die Transformation der gemessenen Drehmomente über die eingestellte Armstellung mir vorne die Kraft ergibt, die der Manipulator gegen seine Umgebung ausübt. Damit kann ich direkt aus der Sensorik, die der Manipulator selber hat, zum Beispiel Fügevorgänge durchführen. Das geht ganz einfach damit. Fügevorgänge? Ja, zum Beispiel Bolzen in ein Loch. Das ist immer so das Problem der Robotik, dass man es nicht sauber hinzubekommen, ohne dass es klemmt.
Das heißt, man muss es einfach komplett über die gesamte Strecke des Arms nachvollziehen, wie die Kräfte sein sollen. Dann hat man aus der Differenz die Rückmeldung aus der Umgebung. Genau. Vielleicht fassen wir noch kurz ein bisschen den Status quo im Weltraum zusammen. Wo gibt es denn überhaupt halbwegs Robotisches? Auch wenn es jetzt vielleicht diesem hohen Anspruch an Sensorik erst mal noch nicht so gelingt. Also es gibt eine ISS.
Eine ISS auf dem Shuttle. Und dann natürlich diese vielen Sonden, die werden alle in den Weltraum geschickt. Das sind ja irgendwo auch Roboter. Die haben Sensoren, die haben ein Programm dazwischen, was frei programmierbar ist. Und meistens auch irgendeine Aktuatorik. Das bezeichnet man eigentlich als Robotersond-System.
Was für eine Aktuatorik haben denn diese Sonden? Ich dachte, die fahren immer noch irgendwo hin und legen Bilder auf.
Ja, die können dann ihre Lage entsprechend bestimmen. Man kann sagen, ich möchte Bilder aufnehmen von einem bestimmten Gebiet. Und da können die sich aktiv auch hintrehen, sodass sie diese Zonen auch sauber aufnehmen können. Oder es gibt Systeme, wo man Gesteinsproben untersucht hat. Das sind ja alles Robotersysteme. Also man muss nicht immer erstmal den Menschen irgendwo hinschicken, um über entfernte Planeten Erkenntnisse zu sammeln. Es geht mit Automaten und Robotern auch. Also es gibt Systeme. Wir haben mal für die ESA an einem Projekt teilgenommen. Da ging es darum, einen kleinen Rover zu konstruieren. Der hat in seiner Kabine, die er da rumfährt, verschiedene Instrumente drin. Kamera, Spektrometer und so weiter. Wir haben dann versucht, mit diesem kleinen Rover an Steine heranzufahren und die Instrumente zu platzieren, sodass man dann direkt auf dem Mars oder auf dem Planeten diese Gesteinsproben analysiert und die Messwerte zur Erde zurück telemetriert. So kann man auch sehr viel über entfernte Planeten erfahren. Man muss nicht immer gleich einen ganzen Roboter arm hinschicken. Es geht auch mit relativ einfachen Systemen. Also kleine Roboter, die Sensorik dann an den entsprechenden interessanten Punkten platzieren. Und damals war es auch die Schwierigkeit, zum Beispiel wie finde ich oder wie findet der kleine Roboter nachher den Stein, der für den Wissenschaftler am Boden interessant ist? Wie navigiert er dahin? Dazu haben wir auch Verfahren entwickelt, wie man in einer Karte, die er sich aufgrund von Stereoinformation, die er vorher oben gesammelt hat, die werden zu Erde runter übertragen, wird eine 3D-Karte aufgebaut. Und man kann jetzt bestimmte interessante Objekte anklicken, dann werden Pfade berechnet, damit der kleine Roboter dahin fährt und diese Gesteine eben entsprechend untersucht. Das ist auch eine Form der Robotik. Aber das Übliche, wo man immer dran denkt, das sind irgendwelche Arme, wie gesagt, auf dem Shuttle oder auf der Raumstation. Und da gibt es, wie gesagt, diese großen 17 Meter langen.
Kurz bei den Rover, das ist ja auch keine Zukunftsmusik, sondern den Mars Rover gibt es ja, wie der NASA. Da ist jetzt aber keinerlei Beteiligung vom DLR dabei gewesen. Oder doch?
Da ist beim Rover selber keine Beteiligung.
Aber die folgen demselben. Die sind ja auch mit Sensorik ausgestattet.
Ja, richtig. Es gibt aber DLR-Beteiligungen, zum Beispiel beim Mars, Mars Orbiter, 3D-Bilder aufnehmen vom Mars. Das ist DLR-Beteiligung. Aber im Prinzip, das, was damals in dem Projekt für die ESA entwickelt wurde, war, schon mehr Autonomie in das System auf dem Planeten zu bekommen. Also, dass man auf der Erde gewisse Zielobjekte auswählt und der Rover selbstständig diese auch anfährt. Das heißt, wenn er jetzt irgendwo an einen kleinen Steinchen angestoßen wäre mit einer seiner Ketten, dann hätte das ihn ja von seinem eigentlichen Pfad abgelenkt. Und wir haben damals oben auf dem Lander eine Stereokamera, die den Rover beobachtet. Die stellt also fest, aha, der weicht von seinem Pfad ab. Dann wurden Korrekturkommandos oben berechnet, sodass er wieder auf seinen vorgegebenen Pfad selbstständig zurückführt. Das heißt, man kann das Ding über viele Stunden sich selbst überlassen. Das war eine relativ interessante Entwicklung, die wir damals, das war ein Auftrag für die ESA.
Also Rover, dann die Arme. Was ist jetzt konkret auf der ISS? Wir haben die Raumstationen schon in einigen Sendungen mehrfach tankiert. Was zum Beispiel in der Sendung zur Astronautenausbildung auch hervorragend war diese kanadische Entwicklung, der Canadarm, beziehungsweise der Canadarm2.
Der kann, wie gesagt, größere Module transportieren. Der kann auf der Raumstation sich bewegen. Der kann quasi krabbeln auf der Raumstation. Der Arm selber? Oder er hat eine mobile Basis. Das ist so ein Schienensystem, auf dem kann er sich entlang bewegen und in verschiedene Orte erreichen. Dann ist noch geplant der ERA-Arm, der European Robotik-Arm. Der ist aber noch am Boden. Ich weiß momentan nicht, ob der in einem der letzten Shuttles noch mit eingeplant ist. Dann ist zurzeit von der NASA der Robonaut oben. Das ist ein zweiarmiges System, womit man demonstrieren will, dass man im Weltraum mit Robotern arbeiten kann, in der Raumstation selber. Wir nehmen an, dass die Amerikaner demnächst anfangen, irgendwelche Demonstrationen in der ISS damit durchzuführen, mit diesem zweiarmigen System. Im Prinzip haben wir ein ähnliches System hier bei uns im Labor stehen. Es fehlt immer mal wieder am Geld, um solche Dinge so zu konstruieren, dass man in den Weltraum bringen kann. Wir wären auch genauso in der Lage, jetzt ein zweiarmiges System in den Weltraum zu schicken. Und das dort oben im Automatikbetrieb arbeiten zu lassen. Dass man sagt, du musst jetzt bestimmte Experimente oben selbstständig bedienen. Oder man steuert das von der Erde aus. Und ich behaupte mal, der Robonaut ist jetzt oben, weil die Amerikaner einfach mehr Geld in diese Entwicklung reinstecken können. Einfach weil sie auch mehr Geld zur Verfügung haben. Aber technologisch hätten wir das schon vor einigen Jahren gekonnt hier. Das ist ein Arm, der oben ist. Dann haben die Japaner ihren Manipulator an der Station.
Also an ihrem eigenen Modul. Ist das auch der, der dieses japanische Versorgungsraumschiff einfängt? Oder wird das mit diesem Canadarmium?
Kann ich momentan nicht sagen. Ich kenne den Plan nicht.
Aber das ist ja sozusagen die Technik, die dort verwendet wird, weil im Gegensatz zu dem ATV, der ESA, was ja automatisch andockt, dockt das japanische Modul ja nicht an.
Ich habe gehört, sie wollen mit Manipulator, dass das Teil greifen und ich nehme an, das machen sie auch mit dem. Aber ganz sicher bin ich mir da nicht.
Jetzt hast du ja vorhin schon erwähnt, dass das eben so, wenn man jetzt mal so auf mögliche Anwendungen der Robotik noch geht, die jetzt so bisher noch nicht abgerufen wurden. Es scheint ja so einiges zu sein, was noch nicht abgerufen wurde. Dass man eben auch Roboter ins All schickt, die jetzt nach anderen Raumfahrzeugen greifen.
Was steckt da dahinter? Da steckt dahinter, dass man Systeme im Weltraum hat, die andere Systeme gefährden können. Weltraumschrott. Das ist ein Thema, das momentan immer wieder durch die Presse geht.
Das hatten wir auch hier schon in der Serie.
Die Raumstation muss öfter mal Kurskorrekturen oder Höhenkorrekturen machen, um irgendwelchen Schrottteilen auszuweichen. Jetzt ging es einfach darum, größere Massen, Raketenoberstufen, ausgedientes Satelliten, möglichst effektiv zu entfernen, bevor sie irgendwas anderes gefährden. Darauf zielt eine unserer Entwicklungen ab. Wir planen mit einem Satelliten, der mit einem Manipulator-Arm ausgestattet ist, an solche Teile heranzufliegen, die zu greifen und ganz gezielt zum Absturz zu bringen. Sodass man sie entsorgt und damit den niedrigen Erdorbit von dem ganzen Schrott freiräumt. Weil wenn wir das nicht tun, haben wir in den nächsten Jahren ein Riesenproblem. Weil es immer wieder vorkommt und häufiger vorkommen wird, dass Stufen kollidieren, kleinere Schrottteile erzeugen, die wiederum treffen andere. Und dieser sogenannte Kessler-Effekt tritt dann richtig ein. Das heißt, wir sind irgendwann mal so weit, dass man ohne Beschädigung eigentlich kein System mehr in den Weltraum bringt. Es muss durch einen Schrottgürtel durchfließen.
Man muss sich nochmal hier einhaken, weil wir das hier schon sehr ausführlich im Raumzeit-Podcast besprochen haben. Falls jemand die Sendung noch nicht gehört hat, kann man auf jeden Fall nochmal darauf verweisen. Ausgabe Nummer 7 mit Holger Krag vom ESA Space Debris Office, der das ja auch sehr plastisch dargelegt hat, wie groß dieses Problem eigentlich tatsächlich ist. Es ist jetzt nicht nur so, na ja, den können wir jetzt mal zur Seite schieben, sondern das ist ja... Man verhagelt sich im Prinzip die Zukunft der Raumfahrt an der Stelle, wenn da eben nicht entsprechend freigeräumt. Na ja gut, also wenn man nicht zumindest jetzt schon darauf achten würde, von vornherein Schrott vermeidend zu operieren. Und trotzdem gibt es immer wieder Schrott, den man schon jetzt schon gerne nicht hätte. Wie realistisch ist denn das? Also, ich meine, das ist ja doch keine ganz unkomplizierte Aufgabe. Überhaupt so nah ran zu fliegen.
Ja, das ist realistisch. Wir haben es in vielen Simulationen durchgespielt. Also, man muss erstmal, das Problem ist, an den Satelliten ranzukommen. Das macht mir üblicherweise so, dass man über absoluten Navigationen die Position des Satelliten kennt, den man anfliegen will, und die Position des anfliegenden Satelliten. Das wird von der Erde aus geträgt über Radarsysteme. Und dann kennt man genau die Position. Irgendwann kommt man in einen Bereich, wo die Sensorik des Service-Satelliten den Zielsatelliten erfassen kann. Egal, ob das jetzt visuelle Sensoren sehen, Kameras, Radar, LIDAR-Systeme. Irgendwann bin ich soweit...
Was ist LIDAR?
Das ist ein Lasersystem, das die Umgebung abscannt und bildgebend arbeitet. Das heißt, ich habe ein Entfernungsbild von dem Objekt, das einen Kilometer oder weiter entfernt sein kann. Wenn ich soweit bin, dass ich über lokale Sensorik auf dem Service-Satelliten den Zielsatelliten erfassen kann, dann schaltet man um auf die sogenannte Relativ-Navigation. Das heißt, der Servicer zieht sich jetzt selber in die Nähe.
Und macht das ohne Unterstützung von Raumstationen?
Berechnet das alles selbst? Das wird vom Boden aus berechnet. Na doch. Man nimmt die Sensorinformationen auf und berechnet, man muss erstmal die Entfernung, das ist das kritische Problem, wenn ich auf die Relativ-Navigation umschalte, dann muss ich möglichst genau die Entfernung kennen, um an den Satelliten hinzufliegen. Man macht das dann ja so, dass man einen Bremsimpuls setzt, der setzt den anfliegenden Satelliten ein Stückchen unter die Bahn des Zielsatelliten und damit bewegt er sich auf ihn zu. Im Weltraum dreht sich das ganze Spieljahr um.
Also unter im Sinne von näher an die Erde heran.
Näher an die Erde heran und damit bewegt er sich schneller. Und bewegt sich an den Zielsatelliten hin. Und im richtigen Moment gebe ich wieder das gleiche Delta V, also den gleichen Impuls drauf und heb ihn wieder an, sodass er auf die gleiche Bahnhöhe kommt, wie der anzufliegende Satellit. Und dann fliegen sie wieder schön hintereinander her. Ich muss natürlich vermeiden, wenn ich zum Beispiel aus 700 Metern Entfernung jetzt den Satelliten anfliegen will, dass ich den treffe. Ich will ja hinter ihm landen, nicht auf ihm. Das heißt, ich muss die Entfernung möglichst genau messen. Und das ist so ein Problem der Sensorik. Was setzt man da ein? Radar, Laser. Wenn man das schafft und kann die Entfernung sehr genau ermitteln, dann kann man sich auch möglichst dicht hinter diesen Zielsatelliten wieder auf die Orbithöhe setzen, sodass man möglichst dicht hintereinander herfliegt. Irgendwann kommt man dann zu dem Punkt, wo man nur noch ein paar Meter von dem System entfernt ist. Und dann macht man einen Anflug, indem man auf dem Orbit so leicht hin und her tanzelt in der Höhe, bis man quasi das Ziel erreicht hat. Und bei uns Ziel erreicht, wenn man mit einem Manipulator dann was tun will, heißt, ich habe einen Abstand von etwa einem Meter zu dem Zielsatelliten. Und ab da kann ich dann mit dem Manipulator-Arm zugreifen.
Das heißt, in dem Moment würde das Gerät den Arm ausfahren und einfach erstmal versuchen, einen Ort zu finden, wo es richtig anpacken kann?
Der Vorgang wird dann so laufen, dass man 20 Meter, 10 Meter vor dem Zielsatelliten erstmal stehen bleibt, mit den eigenen Kameras die Bewegung erfasst von diesem Zielsatelliten. Man geht ja davon aus, dass er nicht still steht, sondern der spinnt um eine Achse oder notiert. Und diese Bewegung, die muss man...
Warum geht man davon aus? Weil er unter Umständen schon komplett außer Betrieb ist und einen Schuss abbekommen hat?
Ja, es ist ein Schrottteil, was unkontrolliert rumfliegt. Die gehen dann nach einiger Zeit in den sogenannten Flat Spin über. Das heißt, die drehen sich um ihre Hauptdreigreizachse mit einer gewissen Schwindigkeit. Und diese Bewegung muss man erst mal genau erfassen.
Das kann aber auch nicht sehr schnell sein, oder?
Ja, aber das sind so üblicherweise so 4 Grad, 10 Grad pro Sekunde. Von so was geht man aus. Und jetzt ist natürlich das Problem, ich muss den ja irgendwo greifen. Das heißt, ich muss mir erstmal... Entweder habe ich im Vorhinein ein Modell vom Hersteller, der mir sagt, pass auf, der Satellit ist so und so konstruiert, hat hier einen Antennenboom oder da sind Solarzellen, da sind Strukturteile, die sind stabil genug, da könnten wir entgreifen. Wenn man das nicht hat, muss man sich erstmal ein Modell zusammenbauen. Das macht man so, dass man einmal das Ziel umfliegt, dabei Aufnahmen schießt und sich sozusagen ein 3D-Modell aus diesen Videodaten selber erzeugt. Dann wird die Bewegung, die Relativbewegung zwischen beiden Satelliten vermessen. Und man kann dann auch vorausberechnen, wie wird sich der Zielsatellit weiterbewegen. Wenn ich das kenne, dann kann der Operator am Boden, ich sag mal in dem 3D-Modell, einen Punkt anklicken und sagen, bitte greif mir den Kollegen an der Stelle. Und da geht es dann automatisch.
Genau das, was wir vorhin schon alles besprochen haben, auch so mit dem Würfel. Man berechnet quasi den Weg wieder vor.
Genau, da kommen die Technologien dann wieder zum Tragen.
Und dann schnappt er sich das Teil.
Und dann schnappt er sich das Teil nur mit dem Unterschied, dass man diesmal, nachdem wir schon ein paar Jahre Entwicklung der Computer hinter uns haben, die Bildverarbeitung auch am Bordsystem rechnen kann. Sodass man da den Regelkreis schneller schließt.
Aber wenn der den dann greift, dann sind ja die Kräfte, die aus dieser Eigenrotation des Satelliten kommen, doch nicht, zumindest nicht unerheblich, oder? Muss man die dann sozusagen mit so einer eigenen Gegenbewegung in dem Moment schon vorher kompensieren?
Ja, es gibt mehrere Methoden. Entweder wenn der sehr schnell dreht.
Kann ja auch sein, dass der da rumfliegt wie so ein Mixer, oder? Wenn der ein paar Mal noch irgendwas anderes getroffen hat.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Wenn ich ihn jetzt einmal anfasse und kann ihn nicht gleich greifen, dann kann aus einer reinen Drehbewegung irgendeine ganz komplexe Bewegung entstehen. Und dann wird es immer schwieriger, vorherzusagen, wie wird er sich in 30 Sekunden hinbewegen haben. Das Problem ist beim Zugreifen. Ich habe ja zwei Körper. Und in dem Moment, wo ich den Greifer schließe, drehen die beiden Körper um einen gemeinsamen Massenschwerpunkt. Vorher waren sie unabhängig.
Der auch ein ganz anderer Schwerpunkt ist und ganz andere Achsen aufmacht als vorher.
Der Schwerpunkt liegt irgendwo zwischen den beiden Körpern. Und auf diese Relativbewegung zwischen dem gegriffenen Satelliten und dem angeflogenen Satelliten muss sich ja irgendwo ausgleichen. Ich muss das Ding abbremsen. Ich muss sie auf gleiche Bewegungen bringen. Und wir machen das so, wie wir Menschen das auch machen würden. Wenn wir ein bewegtes Objekt greifen, dann folgen wir ihm im Arm erstmal mit. Das heißt, wir machen unseren eigenen Arm nicht sehr steif, sondern nachgiebig. Und da kommt dann diese Hybrid-Regelung mit rein, die ich vorher mal erklärt habe, dass man Positionen vorgibt und Drehmomente und lässt ihn das aber ausregeln. Das System verhält sich wie eine programmierbare Feder. Und in dem Moment, wo ich den Greifer schließe, mache ich den Manipulator weich. Der folgt erstmal der Bewegung. Und während dieser Folgebewegung zieht man die Regler immer schärfer an und bremst damit die Bewegungsunterschiede zwischen den beiden Körpern aus.
Also es ist mehr ein Fangen als ein Greifen. Wenn man so bald auf einen zufliegt, dann würde man ja auch den Arm so nach hinten gehen lassen, um den dann irgendwie gut zu fahren.
Ja, wobei wir davon ausgehen, dass wir also nicht auf den zufliegen und aus dem zufliegen heraus zugreifen.
Aber welche Bewegung es auch immer ist, man muss sie halt kompensieren.
Man muss sie kompensieren.
In dem Moment ist es mehr so ein softes, butterweiches Aufnehmen als ein Festhalten.
Weil einfach hart zugreifen, unnachgiebig sein, das würde Riesenprobleme hervorrufen.
Das könnte ja auch Sachen zerbrechen.
Ja klar, dann würde ich auch an diese Strukturteile Riesenfestigkeitsanforderungen stellen. Weil die müssen ja diesen Schlag auch standhalten. Und so kann man an relativ weichen Teilen auch nur angreifen. Oder schwächere Teile greifen, indem ich einfach keine großen Kräfte ins System reinbringe. Und das ist eine Frage der Zeit, die ich mir nehme, um die Relativbewegung auszudämpfen. Und das hängt wiederum mit dem zur Verfügung stehenden Arbeitsraum des Manipulators zusammen. Wenn ich der Bewegung längere Zeit folgen kann, dann kann ich mir auch Zeit lassen, um diese Relativbewegung auszubremsen. Und damit schafft man es wirklich mit relativ kleinen Drehmomenten trotzdem riesengroße Massen zu fangen und auf Relativgeschwindigkeit Null zu bringen. Wir haben das mal durchgerechnet. Wenn man zum Beispiel eine Progress-Kapsel greifen würde, die wiegt 7 Tonnen, wenn sie beladen ist, dann wäre das ein bisschen schwerer.
Also die Kapsel, die die ISS versorgt.
Wenn ich jetzt mit einem System komme, was ebenfalls 7 Tonnen wiegt und habe einen Manipulator drauf und möchte das Ding greifen, dann haben wir mal angenommen, dass die Progress-Kapsel, die wir greifen wollen, mit etwa 4 Grad pro Sekunde um eine Achse spinnt, dann bräuchten wir 40 Sekunden, um das Ding auf Null zu bringen. Und damit hat man ihn aber gegriffen und kann ihn dann zu sich selber her bewegen und irgendwelche Arbeiten daran ausführen. Das ist natürlich jetzt eine riesengroße Masse. Diese 40 Sekunden mit einem Manipulator-Arm, so wie wir ihn jetzt auch schon zur Verfügung haben. Wir hatten ein ähnliches System die ganze Zeit im Weltraum oben auf der Raumstation. Der hat etwa 120 Newtonmeter abtriebseitiges Drehmoment. Und damit schafft man es eben, wie gesagt, in 40 Sekunden diese riesen Masse von 7 Tonnen auf Null zu bringen. Relativ Geschwindigkeit.
Was würden denn da für Anwendungsszenarien noch bei rauskommen? Das Weltraum-Shot-Szenario ist natürlich erst mal sehr naheliegend, weil man sich dann nicht so viel über das Endergebnis Gedanken machen muss. Sie fliegen dann miteinander verbunden in die Ewigkeit.
Oder man platziert eine Antriebseinheit, zündet die und bringt sie zum Absturz. Das ist ja auch eine Methode, die man anwenden kann. Das ist das Thema Weltraum-Shot. Ein zweites Thema wäre die Unterstützung der Astronauten. Wenn die zum Beispiel draußen auf der Raumstation irgendwelche EVA-Aktivitäten durchführen, dann sind die ja stundenlang draußen und müssen Kabel verlegen, Stecker stecken. Also Extra-Vehicular-Aktivities, Raumspaziergang. Da könnte man sehr viele Metropodern erledigen, wenn man sie oben hätte. Das ist eine Zielsetzung, die wir haben. Wir möchten Systeme entwickeln, dass man auch Astronauten bei solchen Arbeiten von der Erde aus unterstützen kann. Dass nicht jemand in der Raumstation den Roboter steuert, das ist ja viel zu teuer. Kruhzeit ist extrem teuer. Das könnte man von der Erde mit Manipulatoren machen, mit Robotern. Die könnten außen rumkrabbeln, zum Beispiel die Raumstation inspizieren. Das sind auch Aktivitäten, die immer wieder während der Weltraumspaziergänge stattfinden. Da kann man überall automatisieren.
Da ist bestimmt die Astronautengewerkschaft dagegen.
Ja, das ist schon richtig. Aber ich glaube, von solchen einfachen Arbeiten lassen sie sich auch ganz gerne helfen. Das heißt zwar Weltraumspaziergang, aber ich glaube, es ist kein richtiger Spaziergang. Wenn man sieht, wie sie gegen die Kräfte im Raumanzug ankämpfen müssen, das ist sehr anstrengend. Und man hört es immer wieder an den harten Arten, wenn man so mal zuhört, während eines EVAs. Das ist wirklich anstrengend. Und ich glaube, sie verlieren auch einige Kilos während so einer Aktivität. Und wenn man sie dabei entlasten kann, da haben sie bestimmt nichts dagegen.
Ja, dieser Mantar, Christopher Reddy, hat das ja auch vor einigen Ausgaben sehr plastisch beschrieben. Wie viel Arbeit macht das überhaupt, alles zu erlernen?
Und ein anderes Szenario, wenn man mal von dem Weltraumschrott weggeht, das ist zum Beispiel Reparieren von Satelliten. Das ist ein anderes Thema. Ich will sie nicht immer entsorgen. Es gibt oft Satelliten, die zum Beispiel nicht genau ihren Zielorbit erreicht haben aufgrund Einschussfehler beim Start. Da kann man mit Service-Satelliten was tun. Und ein anderes Thema, was gerade...
Also sozusagen, welche nochmal retten, die eigentlich sonst verloren wären.
Richtig, ja. Dass man hinfliegt und bringt ihn dahin, wo er hin soll und lässt ihn dort aus. Oder ein anderes Thema ist, es gibt sehr viele Nachrichtensatelliten im geerstationären Orbit, die zum Beispiel Fernsehprogramme übertragen. Die haben eine bestimmte Laufzeit, 12, 15 Jahre. Dann ist üblicherweise der Tank leer und die können ihre Position nicht mehr halten. Da müssen die mit dem Resttreibstoff, den sie noch haben, sich selber entsorgen in den sogenannten Graveyard-Orbit, das sind ein paar hundert Kilometer oberhalb des Geo-Orbits, sodass sie da niemanden mehr stören. Das klingt so ein bisschen wie, ich habe ein schönes Auto, mein Tank ist leer und ich schmeiße es weg. Weil nach zwölf, fünfzehn Jahren, funktionieren die Transponder, die Fernsehkanäle übertragen, meistens noch einwandfrei. Das heißt, wenn man es schafft, die Lebenszeit zu verlängern, kann der Betreiber damit ganz schön Gewinn machen.
Also so ein Nachtankmodul.
Das ist das Komplexe. Wenn ich mir vorstelle, ich fliege an so einen Satelliten hin und möchte ihn nachbetanken, das ist ein ziemlich komplizierter Vorgang. Einmal muss der Satellit auch so gebaut sein, dass ich ihn überhaupt nachbetanken kann. Das ist nicht immer der Fall. Eine andere Methode wäre, die haben wir schon 1988 vorgeschlagen, den Satelliten an seinen sogenannten Apogäumsmotor zu greifen. Der Apogäumsmotor bringt also ein Satellit im geerstationären Orbit wird in die sogenannten, in den Transfer-Orbit geschossen. Das ist eine ganz lang gezogene Ellipse, die hat ihren erdentferntesten Punkt eben das Apogäum bei 36.000 Kilometern etwa. Und wenn ich genau in dem Punkt einen eigenen Antrieb auf einen Satelliten zünde, kann ich aus dieser Ellipse eine Kreisbahn erzeugen und somit wird der Satellit dann geostationär und dreht sich in 36.000 Kilometer Entfernung mit der Erde sauber mit. Und diese Satelliten, diese Nachrichten- Satelliten haben eigentlich alle einen sogenannten Apogäumsmotor. Wenn ich jetzt ein Werkzeug habe, womit ich den Satelliten an diesem Motor greifen kann, dann ist das für uns so was Ähnliches wie ein Docking-Port für die Progress, wenn sie an der ISS andockt.
Warum muss man ihn jetzt genau da greifen? Das ist nicht egal, wo man ihn greift.
Ja, aber das ist ein Teil, das haben alle Satelliten, das schaut bei allen in etwa gleich aus.
Das ist sozusagen so ein genormter Anfasser.
Genau, wir haben einen Teil, was immer in etwa die gleiche Form hat und vor allem, das ist sehr stabil mit der Satellitenstruktur verbunden, weil das Triebwerk muss ja auch die Kräfte des Schubs in die Struktur reinbringen.
Das ist kein Solarpaneel.
Genau, und wenn ich ihn am Solarpaneel packe, dann ist das eine etwas wackelige Konstruktion. Wenn ich ihn am Motor packen kann, dann habe ich eine sehr stabile Verbindung hergestellt. Das hält sozusagen. Wir sind auf die Idee gekommen, 1988 etwa, da wurde der TV-Sat-1 gestartet. Der hat ein Problem, dass er oben im Orbit ein Solarpaneel nicht ausfahren konnte. Da waren Haltemechanismen, die wurden nicht gelöst, konnten nicht gelöst werden und damit ist der ganze Satellit unbrauchbar geworden. Wir wurden damals gefragt, ob wir in der Lage wären, an das Ding hinzufliegen und es zu reparieren. Das Ganze wurde dann in einer Studie durchgezogen. Wir haben damals ein Werkzeug entwickelt, das sogenannte Capture Tool, mit dem man genau in den Apogemus-Motor eintaucht. Das Tool hat Entfernungssensoren, misst damit den Abstand beim Eintauchen zu Düsenwand und kann sich damit schön sauber in den Düsen-Trichter zentrieren. Wir fahren also genau in der Mittelachse durch und fahren mit einem kleinen Spreizmechanismus, das ist ein kleiner Stift, durch die Engstelle der Düse, durch den sogenannten Düsenhals, in die Motorkammer hinein. Und dann wird dieser Stift zurückgezogen, der hat vorne einen kleinen Kegel dran, dann dreht er auf, erhöht damit seinen gesamten Durchmesser und klammert sich wie ein Hohlraum-Dübel in der Motorkammer fest. Und damit habe ich den Satelliten gefangen. Jetzt muss ich ihn nur noch zu mir heranziehen, damit ich auch eine stabile Verbindung habe. Ich setze ihn auf Stützen an dem Service-Satelliten auf und kann dann von dem Service-Satelliten die Lage-Regelung übernehmen. Und das ist eben genau das, was demnächst geplant ist. Und da sind wir gerade auch in Kontakt mit Firmen, dass wir einen solchen Service-Satelliten konstruiert und die Lebensdauer von Nachrichten-Satelliten damit verlängern.
Das ist ja insofern super effizient, als dass man ja die ganze andere Technik nicht nochmal bauen muss, weil die ist ja eh schon da und im Betrieb mit Kontrollzentrum und Pipapo. Man fügt ihm quasi einfach nur neue Düsen und einen neuen Tank hinzu.
Richtig. Man bringt die Lageregelung dorthin.
Und wenn das sich so verallgemeinern ließe, dass man sagt, ok, mehr oder weniger sind die Apogeumsmotoren alle ähnlich. Dass man also erstmal ein Konstruktionsprinzip hat, was vielleicht jetzt nicht out of the box mit jedem Satelliten funktionieren würde. Dann wird es wahrscheinlich immer Anpassungen erfordern. Aber die Anpassungen sind jetzt nicht grundsätzlich, sondern eben nur spezifisch auf das jeweilige Einsatzgebiet. Da könnte man ja im Prinzip auch schon fast über eine Serienfertigung nachdenken, dass man eigentlich immer dasselbe Gerät baut. Dementsprechend natürlich auch so eine Kosteneffizienz macht, wie man sie ja sonst selten hat, weil ja fast jedes Raumfahrzeug für sich wieder anders ist. So dass man dann eben auch billig im Prinzip alles wieder in Betrieb nehmen könnte.
Ja, das ist genau richtig. Und das ist genau auch die Anforderung, die wir haben, dass wir alle gängigen im geostationären Orbit befindlichen Apogeumsmotoren anfliegen können, andocken. Das heißt, wir mussten unser Werkzeug so konstruieren, dass es zu allen Systemen kompatibel ist. Die unterscheiden sich in der Länge des Düsen-Trichters und auch im Düsenhalsdurchmesser. Und jetzt haben wir ein Patent angemeldet für einen Verriegelungsmechanismus, der in der Lage ist, unterschiedliche Düsendurchmesser zu greifen. Und damit wird es dann machbar und auch finanzierbar, dass man einen solchen Satelliten konstruiert für eine Lebenszeit von, ich sag mal, 12 Jahren. Und der kann jetzt unterschiedliche Satelliten im Geo anfliegen und die so 4, 5, 6 Jahre jeweils in ihrer Lebenszeit verlängern, indem man sie so lange auf Position hält.
Und hat ja dann auch selber auch nochmal so ein Andockmodul, wo er dann auch sich an sich selbst andocken könnte.
Und sich selber wieder auftanken.
Naja, dann ist man einfach nochmal andockt. Wie viele nur aneinandergedockt sind, ist ja dann eigentlich auch ziemlich egal.
Nee, die haben ja alle etwas unterschiedliche Positionen. Ich weiß, man könnte jetzt versuchen, an dem anderen wieder so ein Andockmodul anzubringen. Das sind alles, man muss erstmal den ersten Schritt tun. Und man könnte das mit Sicherheit dahingehend erweitert. Oder man kann auch darüber nachdenken, im geostationären Orbit nicht 5, 6, 8 Astra-Satelliten in einer bestimmten Box zu halten, sondern ich schicke da eine große Plattform hoch und baue alle Transponder auf diese Plattform. Das wäre ja auch eine Methode. Wieso muss ich denn so viele...
Eine Satellitenraumstation sozusagen.
Richtig, ja, das wäre eine Idee, worüber man mal nachdenken könnte, um die Anzahl der Satelliten zu reduzieren. Weil es sind ja immer ganz bestimmte Plätze, die sehr interessant sind. Zum Beispiel Astra, 19,8 Grad Ost, da stehen viele Satelliten. Und die dürfen sich gegenseitig auch nicht berühren. Wenn da bei einem die Lage-Regelung ausfällt, aus irgendeinem Grund, dann können seine Nachbarn Probleme bekommen. Und auch dafür, für so einen Fall, wäre es so ein, ich sag mal, Abschleppdienst im Weltraum, der andockt und den wegzieht, sehr hilfreich.
Das ist eine interessante Polonese, die sich dann da oben so in Geo-Orbit ergeben könnte.
Man denkt immer, Weltraum ist groß und es gibt unendlich viel Platz. Wenn man mal anguckt, ist es wirklich eng. Und die Systeme müssen auch sehr genau auf Position gehalten werden. Das heißt, für uns, für den Service-Satelliten, wir haben dann auch hohe Anforderungen an die Positioniergenauigkeit. Also wenn ich Nachrichtensatelliten auf Position halten will, dann muss man sich vorstellen, dass so ein Nachrichtensatellit wiegt etliche Tonnen, sagen wir mal zwei, zweieinhalb Tonnen. Und der angeflogene Satellit ist, man will ja Geld sparen, der Staat soll finanzierbar sein. Man versucht den möglichst leicht zu konstruieren. Der hat dann ein paar hundert Kilogramm. So, wenn ich jetzt an dem Nachrichtensatelliten angedockt bin, dann ist der gemeinsame Masseschwerpunkt nach dem Andocken ja außerhalb des Service-Satelliten. Der liegt wahrscheinlich noch innerhalb des gegriffenen Satelliten. Das heißt, ich muss in der Lage sein, mit der Lageregelung im Service-Satelliten, um einen Punkt zu regeln, der außerhalb des Service-Satelliten liegt. Das ist eine ganz andere Herausforderung. Das macht ein normales Lageregelungssystem nicht. Wenn ich einen Satelliten...
Das ist eine Frage der Software oder auch eine Frage der Positionierung der Düsen?
Genau, das ist eine Frage der Positionierung der Düsen. In dem Fall muss ich die Düsen flexibel positionieren können. Das heißt, nach dem Andocken muss ich die Düsen so in ihrer Orientierung verändern, dass der Schubvektor auf den gemeinsamen Masseschwerpunkt geht. Damit kann ich dann die Korrekturen nachher durchführen.
Was war das, 15 Jahre lebt so ein TV-Satellit? Und wie viele Jahre könnte man ihn dann mit einem zusätzlichen Greifermodul einhauchen?
Der Service-Satellit soll ebenfalls auf 12 bis 15 Jahre Lebenszeit kostelliert sein.
Der dann einfach nur Sprit und Greifer und Düsen hat.
Und zwar ist es dann so, dass man nicht Sprit im üblichen Sinn mit nach oben nimmt, sondern man arbeitet mit Ionentriebwerken. Das heißt, man hat üblicherweise Xenon an Bord als Gas, das dann beschleunigt wird vom Ionentriebwerk. Man muss relativ wenig Masse mit nach oben nehmen und den Hauptanteil der Energie holt man von der Sonne. Und damit lässt sich der Service-Satellit relativ leicht bauen und damit sind die Startkosten auch geringer. Und es dauert ein bisschen länger, bis er auf dem geostationären Orbit landet. Er wird auch in so einem Transfer-Orbit ausgesetzt und spiralt sich dann mit seinem Ionen-Triebwerk über etliche Monate auf den geostationären Orbit. Aber wenn man das rechtzeitig plant, dann kommt man bei dem Zielsatelliten noch rechtzeitig an, bevor dem der Sprit ausgeht, und er muss abgeschaltet werden.
Wie lange würde dann so ein Flug dahin dauern?
Das sind etwa 16 Monate, bis er vom GTO dann in dem Geo landet. Das ist eine Frage der Schubleistung der Triebwerke.
Aber es ist sozusagen ein sehr effizienter Weg. Das dauert nur lange, aber dafür muss man eben nicht so viel Geld aufwenden, um das Ding überhaupt erstmal in Orbit zu kriegen. Und hat dann quasi eine hohe Auswertung der Nutzlast.
Richtig.
Wenn man das jetzt mal so durchspielt, ich meine Roboter, das ist natürlich auch ein sehr emotional aufgeladenes Thema. Ich hab schon vorhin gescherzt mit der Astronautengewerkschaft, aber es wäre ja auch durchaus vorstellbar, dass man das so in die Richtung denkt, dass eben viele der wissenschaftlichen Experimente gegebenenfalls auch von Robotern assistiert werden können, wo heute Menschen eingesetzt werden. So eine reine Robo-Robastronaut-Raumstation. Ist das noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik? Das erfreut natürlich eine ganz andere Autonomie und Vielfalt.
Ja, das sind erst mal auch Sicherheitsbedenken, die erst mal geäußert werden. Wenn ein Roboter auf die Raumstation kommt, dann wäre das momentan nur so machbar, dass man den Abwasbereich des Roboters absperrt, sodass kein Astronaut reinkommt. Das sind einfach Sicherheitsvorkehrungen, die momentan bestehen. Ich glaube, man kann das nur außer Kraft setzen, indem man irgendwann mal vorführt und beweist, dass es machbar ist. Das sind einfach Grenzen, die muss man irgendwann einreißen, indem man demonstriert, was man tun kann. Und das ist auch mit so einem Punkt, weshalb wir immer wieder mit unseren Anforderungen an irgendwelche Grenzen ranlaufen. Wir hatten 2005, also gestartet wurde das System, im Dezember 2004, ein kleines, zweiaxiges Robotersystem auf die Raumstation gebracht. Und zwar nicht wie damals in Rotex innen in die Station, sondern außen, um eben die anfänglich angesprochenen Schwierigkeiten, mit der die Hardware zu kämpfen hat da oben, ebenfalls zu erproben. Und zwar wollten wir ein Robotersystem, was all das Regelungstechnisch kann, was ich vorher mal beschrieben habe, also Drehmoment geregelt, programmierbare Feder, diese Dinge von der Regelung her kann. Das heißt, in jedem einzelnen Gelenkmodul steckt ein relativ komplexer Regelmechanismus drin. Das heißt, ich brauch da drin auch Rechenleistung. Jetzt kann man das alles weltraumqualifiziert aufbauen, so wie man das üblicherweise macht, dass man zugelassene Prozessoren kauft, die schon Strahlen getestet sind und so weiter. Dann endet man aber mit einem System, was mindestens doppelt so groß ist, wie das, was wir jetzt gebaut haben, und viel, viel teurer. Wir wollten einen ganz anderen Weg gehen. Wir haben Leichtbau-Roboter-Systeme hier im Labor entwickelt, die etwa dem menschlichen Arm entsprechen, von ihrer Komplexität und Bewegungsfähigkeit. Wir wollten diese Gelenkmodule in den Weltraum bringen. Dann sind wir hergegangen und haben untersucht, die Komponenten, die wir jetzt in dem Leichtbau-Roboter verbaut haben, würden die den Belastungen im Weltraum standhalten. Wir haben ein Robotergelenk genommen, sind damit in eine Strahlenkammer gegangen und haben das radioaktiv bestrahlt, geguckt, welche Komponenten schwächeln denn dabei. Die müsste man austauschen. Das haben wir dann auch getan. Das war gar nicht so schlimm, wie wir anfangs nicht gedacht hatten. Wir mussten einige Komponenten austauschen und zum Beispiel Elektrolytkondensatoren durch Tantalkondensatoren ersetzen. Das sind so gängige Dinge, die man dann tut. Wir haben die Gelenkmodule umkonstruiert, sodass wir glauben, dass sie im freien Weltraum standhalten. Eben, um Roboter-Systeme bauen zu können, mit denen man all das im Weltraum tut, worüber wir gerade gesprochen haben. Ich möchte einen Arm haben, der im freien Weltraum funktioniert. Und dadurch haben wir, wir haben es mit diesem Projekt geschafft, mit Standard-Teilen, wie sie im Prinzip in jedem Elektronikladen kaufen können, Gelenkmodule zusammenbauen und die in den Weltraum zu schicken. Die mussten natürlich alle diese Qualifikationen nachweisen. Wir mussten die Gelenkmodule schütteln, wir mussten Thermal-Vacuum-Tests bestehen, gucken, wie heiß werden die denn im Vakuum, hält es denn alles stand. Das heißt, wir haben konstruktiv alles das mit eingebaut, was wir vor vielen Jahren bei Rotex schon mal gemacht haben. Plus den Zusatz, jetzt sind wir im Freien, wir können nicht mit dem Ventilator da oben Luft umwirbeln, sondern man muss die Wärmeenergie irgendwie nach außen bringen. Das heißt, alle Teile, die Wärme erzeugen, sind über Metallverbindungen an die Außenwand angekoppelt. Und die Außenwand hat eine Thermalfarbe bekommen, die in der Lage ist, Energie abzustrahlen im Weltraum, aber relativ wenig Energie von der Sonne aufzunehmen. Dafür gibt es ganz speziell gefertigte Thermalfarben.
Ist das nicht einfach weiß?
Es sieht grau aus, aber wie gesagt, die haben unterschiedliche Koeffizienten, was die Abstrahlung oder Aufnahme der Sonnenenergie betrifft. Und damit schafft man es, das Innenleben der Gelenkmodule auf einigermaßen verträglichen Temperaturen zu halten.
Was sind das für Temperaturen?
Temperaturen halten wir etwa zwischen minus 20 und plus 60 Grad. Aber das ist schon ein ganz schöner Temperaturbereich. Wenn es kälter wird, wenn wir längere Zeit ausgeschaltet sind, dann haben diese Gelenkmodule auch Heizfolien drin. Da wird Heiz in den Strom angelegt und da werden die auf Betriebstemperatur geheizt. Das kann man machen. Das andere Problem, was wir noch hatten, das war die ganze Schmierung, weil man kann ja nicht einfach normales Fett oder Öl nehmen. Das verdampft im Vakuum. Da gibt es ganz spezielle Schmiermittel. Und die mussten wir natürlich auch verwenden. Und für uns waren mehrere Dinge interessant. Wir wollten feststellen, können wir überhaupt eine Elektronik bauen, die über längere Zeit im Weltraum überlebt, ohne kaputt zu gehen? Und das mit möglichst günstigen Bauteilen. Das muss ja nicht immer alles elend teuer werden. Und wir hatten uns damals überlegt, dass wir dieses Experiment, das heißt ROCKWIS, Roboter, Komponenten, Verifikation auf der ISS, dass man das mal ein Jahr lang betreibt auf der Raumstation. Und dann sieht, okay, gibt es Schwachstellen? Muss man irgendwo was korrigieren? Oder liegen wir mit unserem ersten Ansatz, Gold richtigen, können so weitermachen? Das System wurde insgesamt fast sechs Jahre betrieben auf der Raumstation. Und zwar war es am russischen Modul außen angebaut. Und wir haben immer wieder im Prinzip jeden Monat Experimente durchgeführt und haben Vergleichsmessungen gemacht zu Experimenten, die wir vorher durchgeführt haben, um festzustellen, ob irgendwas degradiert an den Systemen. Also steigt die Reibung an, fallen Elektronikkomponenten aus? Wie verhält sich das System? Und wir haben nach fünfeinhalb Jahren Betrieb eigentlich immer noch keine gravierenden Mängel festgestellt. Das heißt, wir sind eigentlich ziemlich sicher, dass wir mit der Methode, mit gängigen Bauteilen Roboter-Systeme bauen können, mit denen man sehr wohl Servicing im Weltraum betreiben kann, kosteneffektiv. Und das ist zwar mit ein Hauptanliegen. Man kann natürlich alles riesengroß und schwer bauen und strahlenfest, aber es geht auch so. Und wenn man das jetzt in ein Manipulatorsystem integriert, was zum Beispiel da oben Satelliten einfangen soll, dann kann man die gesamte Ansteuerelektronik auch redundant auslegen. Das heißt, man hat einmal diese Mechanismen drin, die ich vorher mal erklärt hab, die einen Ledge-Up-Schutz darstellen. Das heißt, wenn die von Ionen getroffen werden, dass sie nicht abbrennen, das ist auf jeden Fall drin enthalten. Aber man baut dann den gesamten Antriebsstrang doppelt auf. Das heißt, wenn aus irgendeinem Grund ein Antrieb ausfällt, dann kann man auf die andere Elektronikseite umschalten. Solche Dinge, das würde dann in den kommenden Robotern, die wir in den Weltraum schicken wollen, integriert. Aber dieses Rockwis-Experiment diente dazu, einmal die Grundidee zu überprüfen, schaffen wir es überhaupt, einen Roboter zu bauen, der so lange zuverlässig arbeitet. Die andere Komponente war noch die Steuerung dabei. Weil wenn man an Reparatur denkt, dann kann man nicht immer alles vorher planen oder ein System hochschicken, was so autonom ist, dass es alle Aufgaben selber erledigen kann. Da sind wir noch weit davon entfernt. Das heißt, sehr effektiv ist es dann, den Menschen in die Schleife mit einzubinden. Das heißt, dass ein Operator am Boden sitzt und hat so was Ähnliches wie ein Exos-Klett. Schlupft mit dem Arm rein oder bewegt einen Manipulator an seiner Eingabestation. Durch die erreichten Gelenkstellungen bewegt sich dann der Manipulator oben im Weltraum entsprechend. Entscheidend dabei ist aber, dass der Operator am Boden spürt, was der Manipulator oben spürt.
er muss dieselben Kräfte wiederum abbekommen.
Genau. Und das haben wir mit bei diesem Experiment erprobt. Das sind erstmal Grenzen der Kommunikation da gewesen, die wir beseitigen mussten.
Das muss natürlich schnell gehen.
Das muss schnell gehen. Das soll auf jeden Fall deutlich unter einer Sekunde sein. Wir sagen immer so etwa 500 Millisekunden. Latenzzeit ist so die Obergrenze, womit man noch effektiv im Telepräsenz-Mode arbeiten kann. Man fühlt sich telepräsent an dem Ort, dadurch, dass man Kräfte spürt, die der Manipulator spürt, und man hat ein Real-Time-Stereo-Bild. Man sieht, was das Ding tut. Und genau die Dinge haben wir bei diesem Experiment erprobt. Wir haben einen kleinen Joystick mit Kraftdrückmeldung an unserer Bodenstation. Damit steuern wir den Roboter auf der Raumstation an einer Kontur entlang. Der Roboter hat nur zwei Achsen. Der hat eine Drehachse und eine für rauf runter. Vorne ein Taststift dran. Damit kann ich aber an einer Kontur entlangfahren. Oder ich kann mich auch mit dem Taststift in so einen Haken einhängen und eine Feder ziehen. So, zum Beispiel diese Experimente konnten wir von der Erde aus im Telepräsenz-Mode durchführen. Wir haben ein Stereobild gehabt.
Und wie war die Übertragungslatenz?
Die Latenz, die wir dann hinbekommen haben, war 12 Millisekunden, wenn die Raumstation über Deutschland steht.
Weil dann kann man direkt funken.
Dann kann man direkt. Wir haben eine eigene Funkstation auf der Raumstation installiert. Eine eigene Sender-Empfangseinheit. Und wir haben über unsere Bodenstation des DLR hier in Weilheim die Station aufgefasst und dann die Verbindung aufgebaut für die Überflugszeit von etwa 8 Minuten. Je nach Orbit kann man 8 Minuten lang mit dem System dort arbeiten. Und in den anderen 82 Minuten? Erst mal außerhalb der Reichweite. Ich habe keine direkte Funkverbindung. Aber in diesen Zeiten haben wir auch im Automatikbetrieb Experimente durchgeführt. Also da wurden Aufgaben an das System nach oben übermittelt, die es dann ausgeführt hat über ein zeitgesteuertes Kommando. Da hat es geheißen, um so viel Uhr startest du das und das Programm. Das wurde dann automatisch oben ausgeführt.
Also es gab jetzt keine zweite Basisstation, die mit demselben Funkmodul reden kann.
Das könnte man machen, aber unseren Betrieb konnten wir mit einer Station abwickeln. Wir wollen ja, wie gesagt, nur die Gelenke überprüfen, ob sie funktionieren und diesen Telepräsenzbetrieb das erste Mal operationell durchführen. Und das waren auch so Dinge, wir mussten viel Neuland betreten. Man musste an der Bodenstation einiges ändern, sodass man direkten Zugang zu den Sender- und Empfangseinheiten an der Bodenstation bekommt. Das heißt, unsere Roboter-Bodenstation wurde direkt an die Senderempfangseinheit in Weilheim angekoppelt. Und nur dann schafft man es, diese Latenzzeit so weit runterzudrücken, weil sonst landet man wieder im Sekundenbereich. Aber nachdem das jetzt hervorragend funktioniert hat, wird man diese Methode auch für zukünftige Service-Roboter einsetzen können. Und wenn man das jetzt erweitert, man hat nicht nur zwei Achsen, sondern einen Manipulator mit einer künstlichen Hand dran, die zum Beispiel auch Kräfte misst in den Fingern und mir das zurücktelemetriert in meinen Datenhandschuh, mit dem ich die Hand ansteuere am Boden, dann kann man sich vorstellen, ich kann als Mensch dort oben ganz komplexe Handhabungsvorgänge ausführen. Und es muss nicht immer ein Astronaut aussteigen. Ich kann dann mit Datenhandschuh und Roboterhand Schrauben reindrehen und Dinge montieren, weil ich einfach spüre, was der Roboter spürt.
Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal zum Ende nochmal auf einen anderen Effekt. Ich will es jetzt nicht den Teflon-Effekt nennen, aber man fragt sich ja immer, wie lässt sich die Erkenntnisse auf den Boden einsetzen. Zum Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme befinden wir uns immer noch so voll in den Auswirkungen dieser Fukushima-Atomkatastrophe, deren konkreter Ausgang sich jetzt hier zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme noch nicht so richtig absehen lässt. Aber was dort auf jeden Fall auch ein Problem ist, ist eben das Reparieren von Gerät in einer extrem lebensfeindlichen Umgebung, wo es auch eben mit Radioaktivität viel zu tun hat. Kann man denn auch für solche Umgebungen, Robotik, da gibt es sozusagen auch schon so Erkenntnisse, wenn ich jetzt höre, so Radioaktivität bedroht das Gerät und soweit ich mich erinnere, wurde ja auch in Tschernobyl seiner Zeit versucht mit automatischen Geräten da aufzuräumen, was dann eben misslungen ist, weil die nach kurzer Zeit einfach den Dienst eingestellt haben. Gibt es da schon?
Ja gut, das Problem dabei ist natürlich die hohe Radioaktivität. Man muss sich vorstellen, wenn ich in so einen Reaktor reingehe, der nicht mehr kontrollierbar ist, dann geht nach relativ kurzer Zeit bei den Kameras die Lichter aus, einfach weil die Optik dunkel wird aufgrund der Strahlung. Also man muss dieses Problem lösen. Es gibt es natürlich Glassorten, die dem Effekt längere Zeit widerstehen, aber soweit ich weiß, gibt es keine, die das dauerhaft überleben. Zum anderen muss man diese Roboter, die dann in so eine Umgebung reinfahren sollen, downscalen in der Komplexität. Ich darf da nicht so hochkomplexe Dinge fliegen, weil einfach durch die Packungsdichte, mit denen diese Computer, die wir da in den Gelenken drin haben, die würden aufgrund der hohen Packungsdichte der Strahlung nicht widerstehen. Ich muss dann wieder auf einfachere Komponenten zurückgehen, im Prinzip, wenn ich es schaffe, sogar auf einzelne Transistoren. Und die sind dann wieder sehr strahlensicher. Das heißt, das System, das ich in diese strahlenverseuchte Umgebung schicke, das muss diese Umgebung natürlich standhalten. Und da gibt es konstruktiv Möglichkeiten, aber irgendwann gehen die alle kaputt. Also bei den hohen Strahlung gibt es meines Wissens nichts, was da über Monate überleben kann. Aber diese ganzen Steuerungskonzepte, Telepräsenz, ich kann da reinfahren und mal schnell irgendwo was anflanschen. Das lässt sich auf jeden Fall damit erledigen. Und insofern kann man diese Technologien, die wir jetzt hier im Weltraum erproben, natürlich auch auf der Erde einsetzen. Oder Steuerungsgeräte, zum Beispiel diese kleine Space Mouse oder diese Kugel, wie wir sie nennen, die wird inzwischen mit einer Lizenz gefertigt. Und die steht an vielen Computersystemen als Eingabegerät, zum Beispiel zur Eingabe an Grafiksystemen. Das ist eben diese 6D-Mouse, die Kräfte und Momente spürt. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die eigentlich aus der Raumfahrt kommt. So gibt es vieles. Oder auch die Steuerung von Robotern in der Medizin. Minimal invasive Chirurgie zum Beispiel. Das ist ein Thema, mit dem beschäftigen wir uns auch hier im Institut. Da warten wir an Roboter, die Instrumente im Körper platzieren können und bewegen können. Und jetzt hat der Operateur ein Eingabegerät, bei dem er auch wieder die Kräfte spürt, die der Roboter im Körper innen drin aussieht. Und jetzt kann man diese Eingabegeräte natürlich auch so gestalten, dass die Bewegung skaliert wird. Das heißt, wenn der Operateur einen etwas zittrigen Tag hat, dann kann man das so runterskalieren, dass trotzdem noch eine präzise Bewegung unten ankommt. Und man kann damit...
Die Kantenglittung sozusagen.
Man kann damit sehr effektiv arbeiten. Und man kann das auch über die Ferne tun. Das heißt, ich kann auch einen Spezialisten, der in einer ganz anderen Stadt wohnt, dazuschalten, ohne dass der jetzt vor Ort sein muss. Und der kann aus der Ferne operieren und so weiter. Es gibt da sehr viele Anwendungsmöglichkeiten für diese Technologien. Und das sind einfach immer Barrieren, die man hat. Im Weltraum ist es die Entfernung und die Umgebung. Und im menschlichen Körper zum Beispiel der Durchstich durch die Bauchdecke, der Druckarpunkt, wo sich dann die Bewegungen innen einfach umkehren. Das kann ein Manipulator sehr gut mitrechnen. Das heißt, der Operateur muss nicht umdenken. Wenn er das bisher macht, muss er, wenn er unten nach links fahren will, oben nach rechts fahren und so weiter. Das sind alles Dinge, die dem Menschen die Arbeit erleichtern. Dazu sind Roboter ja eigentlich gedacht.
Was sich schon mal die Haare selbst vom Spiegel geschnitten hat.
Das ist genau das Thema. Das schlägt da genau zu.
Ja, Klaus, das war ein super Flug hier. Wir sind ja schon über zwei Stunden im Orbit.
Die Zeit ist schnell vergangen.
Ja, die Zeit ist schnell vergangen. Das ist auch ein unerschöpfliches Thema. Aber ich glaube, das haben wir jetzt ganz gut abgesteckt und auch mal ganz gut aufgezeichnet, was sowohl schon zum Einsatz kommt und was noch alles zum Einsatz gebracht werden könnte. Mit der Robotik in der Raumfahrt. Insofern vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Ja, und wie immer auch vielen Dank an alle, die zugehört haben hier bei dem spannenden Thema. Und wir haben, wie es so ist, noch weitere spannende Themen hier geplant, die hier kommen sollen bei Raumzeit. Das war es auf jeden Fall schon mal für heute. Ich sage Tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal.